from my tribe. His name is ASmart and he's going to make a funny
two. And remember, it's never violent as long as we're telling
jokes. And it said in front of a comedian, take it away, >> No
one in the United States should be retiring at 65 years old.
Frankly, I think retirement itself is a stupid idea unless you
have some sort of health >> I wonder if I slap the you
would be anti-mitted cuz I don't want to be anti-mitted. I just
want to slap the [__] out.
>> Never mind. She won. She actually won.
So, do we want to go to the beginning of this Candace Charlie
stuff? I think we do. I think we do. And I'm going to I'm going
to speed through a lot of it
>> it doesn't go back that far. Okay. It doesn't go back
that far. But,
but
this is where it starts. Okay, hold on. This might just be the
Egyptian plane stuff. Is it? Turning Point has kept a big secret.
Is this about Turning Point and a French connection? This is
the Dupont thing. He's like He's going back over this Dupont
error. gets no prison time for three-year-old daughter. Bro,
what?
French people got problems, dog. This is the Dupont stuff. And
then I think they talk about those Egyptian planes.
Yes, these are the Egyptian planes after Charlie Kirk got so
Candace goes over that. Okay. Or sorry, this is a different timeline
actually,
but I think we can skip all of that. Charlie was prophetic.
I believe this will be the turning point. >> Interesting
tip. >> So, we're going to go through the turning point
stuff cuz this actually blew up into way way more. What? Lol.
Yeah, Candace has two insanely schizophrenic fights going on
right now. One is with Turning Point USA. The other one was with
the French government. And and they both, I think, have some
connection to the assassination of Charlie Kirk. Okay. The French
Foreign Legion, she believes trained the assassin of Charlie
Kirk. All right. And
do I No, hold on. This is actually going to be all related.
Oh my god. I have to watch the whole thing. Okay. We're going
to go. We're just going to go. I actually want to begin this
episode with a comment. >> We have to watch the whole thing
cuz the French government has now her primary enemies in the
French government have been tied into Charlie Kirk's assassination.
All right. And we watched a little bit of her going through like
the property records in uh Delaware. Delaware. Madison, Delaware.
No, not Madison. Somewhere where the Dupont family's from. DuPont
family, Delaware.
>> where where are they in the there's there's like one
of the places they primarily live. Hold. Primarily live. Give
me a second. It's the
Where did they Wilmington? Wilmington, Delaware. Yes. So, she
went through property records in Wilmington. Was like, "Oh, look.
They all own property records around where my lawyers are and
around where this hanger is that takes off when Charlie Kirk
passes away like shortly after." She I think they hypothesized
that for some reason this plane took off and flew the assassins
out of the country >> from yesterday's episode because
you know we ran that poll wondering whether or not the public
agreed with me about my lawsuit me being filed by Bridget McRone
being sued by Bridget and Emanuel Mcronone and whether or not
it was just one big federal setup meant to bankrupt me and here
was an answer that we got in the comment section. Look at this.
I believe that the purpose of Mcronone's lawsuit was that it
was supposed to go nowhere because Candace was supposed to have
been assassinated before the case got to court. then they could
forever claim that Candace was lying, which is evident by the
fact that they were suing her for quote unquote defamation before
>> Bro, who does this whole thing better, Destiny or Candace
Owens? Which one of them does this this entire song and dance
where they just like totally totally like trick their audience
into believing something that's totally fake? Which one does
it better? I think Candace does it better to be honest you with
you. Okay, Candace is pretty good. >> This was their plan,
but I pray that it has now been foiled. I had never considered
that and that hit really deeply and that is a dark thought and
I think now I am I'm wondering I have a lot of questions. Everything
feels different in this post Charlie Kirk world. Where to begin?
How about we should talk about the founding of America because
man those Catholic priests that I was telling you about they
were unbelievably correct. I told you guys a long time ago how
when I was considering whether or not I should be Orthodox or
Catholic but I knew that I was sort of done with Protestantism.
I had been taking instruction from these priests in Europe and
in the UK. And one of the fathers is a real bookworm, right?
Kind of this canankerous
>> no time for the American education system whatsoever.
And he said to me quite famously, you Americans know nothing
of your own history. Your country was founded by Freemasons.
And that just kind of permanently now echoes in my ear because
boy was he right. A war that had been sort of waging across Europe
for centuries had then spilled into America. Was largely a spiritual
war. It was really a theological war. That's what I'm starting
to realize. That's why America never really had an appetite for
orthodox or Catholicism because the Catholics and the Orthodox
have kept history. They know what was going on in Europe, not
the fake history that's packaged and sold to Americans. They
know what the Freemasons were up to. Freemasons who caused all
of those revolutions against really the Christian empire across
Europe. The idea really, I now think, is keep Americans fat and
dumb and drugged and propagandized.
>> bro? It's like he really is just becoming Alex Jones.
Very funny >> when we need to use their men to mass murder
other Christians overseas. That's the big picture that I'm beginning
to >> All of this to say, did you know that our FBI was
founded by Charles Joseph
>> I had no idea. I I hate to be American ignorant, but
I had no idea. And yes, that man was the founder. And yes, uh
that is like Napoleon Bonapart. His grandfather, Charles's grandfather
was Napoleon Bonapart's brother. This is like
was his great uncle.
Guys, I don't know if you knew this, but America
was actually founded by
Crazy history. Crazy history fact.
Europeans came from Europe to America. They hide this from you,
okay? They pretend that you don't know that Europeans came from
Europe into America and rich Europeans started the industrial
revolution in America. I have little known fact, okay? Little
known fact. This has always been a hidden hidden thing, okay?
a hidden history of >> Bonart was his great uncle, which
makes it kind of hilarious, right? Because our tip yesterday
from that person in Wilmington, Delaware, was asserting that
the FBI had these offices, these kind of hidden offices, maybe
kind of in buildings that appear to be in part controlled by
French American families who might have some conflicted interests.
Particularly, we were discussing the DuPont family, right? Mentioning
the Dupont family led to a flurry of tips coming out of Delaware.
It was incredible. people in Wilmington saying, "Uh, yeah, no,
they own kind of everything. Like everything, hospitals, schools,
buildings, you name it, it is theirs." And then we received
>> Yeah. No. No. This is like one of the richest families
in American history. No. They own everything in the city where
they like built their businesses.
Yeah. They're like a billionaire family. Um, as of 2016, the
family fortune was estimated at 14.3 billion spread across more
than 3,500 living relatives. Of course, that family that like
I guess Yeah. the the money sort of like spread out now. Yeah.
They've got the Teflon. It's DuPont has the Teflon thing. And
then they also the the like founder of the family, the guy who
first came to America and lived in in Wilmington was the head
of General Motors in like the 1800s or something,
right? Which one is Which one was this guy?
Was it this guy? Was it this guy? I think this is the guy we
looked at, right? No, no, no, no. That's obviously way too young.
Jesus. or way too old. Way too old. Who's who's the guy who served
for General Motors? Uh the guy we looked up yesterday, he was
like the head of General Motors. It's like, yeah, of course,
if he got stuck in General Motors like early on, then yeah, they're
of course they're [__] rich. >> Some more tips
from people who were invested in sort of the urban legends of
the DuPont family. They were telling us, "Hey, I went to school
with Dupont." Like there's a lot of stories there and these stories
sound a lot like what you were covering in your becoming Breit
series. You remember actually right before we had uh been sort
of interrupted in becoming Bridget series 2 uh season 2 we were
speaking about Eric Dupond Moretti Eric Dupon Moretti and we
were speaking about how he was kind of known in a name for himself
making an argument for happy.
Yeah. Uh people were telling us >> is this somebody with
a name that sounds kind of similar to Deont but isn't
is that is that what I'm sensing here that she's trying to connect
it to somebody who has a similar sounding >> Dupont family.
There's a lot going on there and they've also maybe been involved
in some murders. Again, this was DuPont folklore if you will.
But then more emails came in and you know what? It's not entirely
folk. >> Okay. It's not Dupal versus DuPont like with Okay.
>> Okay. It's really not. This is actually an article that
appeared in Vanity Fair. So, let's read it together. And I'm
going to issue a trigger warning right at the top because it
is disturbing. Today's episode in general, I should say, is not
for the faint of heart. Here's the headline. DuPont Air gets
no prison time for three-year-old daughter. Okay. And the person
who emailed us over said, "This has actually kind of lived in
me for over a decade because I was so disturbed by the story
and you should read this." And it tells us that Robert Richards
IV was in
>> Oh, the Dupants are also responsible for lobbying to
make hemp illegal because they re they invented nylon during
World War II convicted of his three-year-old daughter u seven
years after. >> Now, here's the thing
that couldn't possibly survive today and nobody makes stuff out
of hemp. So, like was hemp ever really going to win? Did they
just do that and then like stuff would hemp would be way more
useful. It's illegal again, by the way. Okay, but like if if
hemp products
were illegal, if the stuff you could make with hemp was was allowed,
sorry. If it was allowed,
if it was just way better, why wouldn't it just be allowed?
It's one of those things where I just don't I don't think you
can overcome the market that strongly anymore.
Hemp is very versatile. Okay, maybe I'm thinking I'm thinking
of like um clothing then.
>> I'm I'm thinking of clothing or something, I guess.
She, who was just five, told relatives that she didn't want her
father to be touching her
>> Okay, hold on. There's got to be a YouTube video on
this, right? Give me a second. Hemp versus nylon. Do Paul. Wait,
that's an Instagram reel. Get out of here. >> Did you know
that paper?
>> Hold on. 5 minute video. Just I tried to find something
on the topic. >> Played a major role in making marijuana
illegal. In this video, we'll dive deep into the history of how
corporate greed led to the ban on marijuana and the devastating
effects it had on individuals and communities. To begin, it's
simple to understand the historical context of >> Okay,
I can't. Never mind.
What the What the hell? Oh, it's Strange Show is the YouTube
channel. I get it. I
dude, what the hell? What the This is like the This is what I
picture the person who's like telling me actually hemp products
would be really useful. I just I can't see. But maybe maybe they'd
be maybe like we totally run society completely inefficiently
for that exact
Maybe nylon rope versus hemp rope. Which one is a rock climber
using? I actually don't know. Which one is it?
Nylon rope versus hemp rope. Which one are they >> Marijuana
in the United States. At the turn of the 20th century, can flour
wasn't common in the United States. And it was really used among
Americans. When the start of the Mexican revolving 1910, many
Mexicans began moving to the United States. And they brought
with them the tradition of smoking marijuana. The influx of Mexican
immigrants and their use of cannabis often referred to as marijuana
at the time created a world pic among some white Americans who
saw it as a dangerous and corrupting influx. But it was more
than just some citizens who were concerned. Some big corporations
were really scared too. And that's what we're going to be looking
at today. During the early 20th century, the paper industry was
a powerful and influential force in American site. At the time,
paper was primarily made from trees and the process was costly
and timeless. However, in 196 that could produce paper from hemp,
a plant that grows quickly and abundant. Paper was cheaper and
more efficient to produce than paper and posed a significant
threat to the paper industry.
>> Okay, this is why I've always heard that hemp was banned
was because it was the it was a paper substitute instead of pulp
and it was like way better, right? This is what I'd always heard.
not like nylon or or something duplic
was really scary for these men and millionaires in the the head
industry. So William Rand first who was basically a newspaper
got cotton who owned almost all >> oh I know the whole
country began publishing articles that demonized marijuana and
portrayed it as a dangerous drug that led to violence and insanity.
So since he owned a majority of the newspapers, he could just
print anything he wanted in the newspapers that made marijuana
seemed absolutely insane. And back then the general public wasn't
doing a whole lot of fact checking. If you saw something in the
newspaper, you just assumed it to be fact. He didn't stop the
stories of violence and insanity. Her newspapers also promoted
the idea that marijuana was primarily used by Mexican immigrants
and African-Americans, which played on racial prejudices and
fears among the American public because at the time that America
was >> a pig.
>> Reuben donated $3. Bro went from asking questions to
asking them >> really racist. And there was racist going
around at the time trying to get people scared about other races
of people. And so just blinding them that he said, "Yeah, those
other racism people are scary and dangerous." And the reason
why is because they all smoke marijuana and that [__]
makes sane. And he just printed any old advice he wanted to in
these newspapers because he owned the newspaper and nobody even
knew they were lies. I don't care. Just print whatever you want.
Say any crazy [__] about you want and everybody's
going to believe it. Around the same time, the chemical company
Dupont had developed a new product called nylon. >> Oh,
hold on, hold on.
They made nylon >> which was made from chemicals. Nylon
was a revolutionary product that could be used to make a wide
range of consumer goods from clothing to tires. However, Dupant
faced stiff competition from companies that produce goods made
from hemp, including rope, twine, and even clothing. The success
of the hemp industry threatened Dupont's profits and its monopoly
on the synthetic fiber market. And even though William Randph
or anyone at DuPont couldn't actually pass any laws themselves,
they did have tons of money to hand out to get whatever they
And they did lobby the government very aggressive and with lots
of that money to keep marijuana illegal. And it didn't take much
of this lobbying money before the government took action. In
1937, just a handful of years after Willie Weederhurst started
publishing anti-weed propaganda in his newspapers and Hurst and
Dupont started lobbying the government, the Marijuana Tax Act
was passed by Congress, which effectively criminalized marijuana
at the federal level. And in 1937, the same exact year that the
Marijuana Tax Act was passed, Dupant finally felt safe from competition.
And they patented a process for making plastics from oil and
coal, which made nylon and other synthetic materials way more
profitable. And as a bonus, it was terrible for the planet. the
paper industry and the plastic making giant DuPont which had
both already been lobbying against hemp for years saw the marijuana
tax act as a way to eliminate its most fear.
Okay, so to me while DuPont did lobby with uh Hurst to get the
hemp industry like defunded to get it elite like
it seems like okay we actually figure out how to make nylon out
of some other synthetic process and actually it was way more
profitable and we don't care about it anymore. Right. >> Careful
competition. Hemp papers and hemp plastics could have easily
replaced all of their products for much cheaper and with way
less impact on the >> well they could have. >> But
instead of just trying to buy the patent surrounding the hemp
industry, they just paid to get rid of the hemp industry altogether.
Imagine how much different things could be today if biodegradable
and sustainable hemp plastics would have became the
>> Oh. Oh, hold on. Wait. But then how long? Wait, is that
a positive? I think the whole idea of like Hold on. I thought
the whole idea of like having plastic stuff. When does this start
biodegra? When does it start degrading?
Because like would you want to just have like a 7-Eleven and
suddenly all the Gatorade stops starts like flooding out? Yeah.
Like the whole shelf life. Yeah. The idea of shelf life.
That's I like this could be really good in some cases. Yeah.
Yeah. It could be good in some cases. Also, I just don't believe
that the I don't believe something that's not created from a
chemical process is going to be more like efficient at this point.
of all this one time used plastic that we're sending to the landfill.
The dorks in the government had really hated cannabis for a long
time. >> Okay. All right. I think that's enough enough
context there. >> Says in an alarming twist, the judge
who sentenced the heir to the Dupont fortune
no jail time, arguing that the 6'4 Richards will not farewell
in prison. That was the argument that the lawyer made and the
courts in Delaware found that to be valid. So instead of sentencing
him for prison for a toddler, it goes on and tells us that Judge
Jan Jordan ruled that Richards would benefit from treatment instead.
Critics have since noted that such treatment is usually offered
only to drug addicts or those in possession of child. >> Okay,
so she's going to talk about the Dupants for a little bit and
then where she ends is where we were yesterday. So this is this
is her like skitso map from yesterday. She's like this is Wilmington,
Delaware. Here's where our lawyers are with the DEA, FBI, and
United States Secret Service office. Okay. And then I guess she's
showing some other stuff that the Dupants own around this. I
think the Duponts technically own all of these buildings. Okay.
And one of these is the one of these buildings is the owner of
the hangar or possibly the hanger itself. Oh, Bridget Mcron's
lawyers are right here. And then where's the hanger? Do these
people own a brace bridge complex, I think, is where the hanger
is where the plane took off to go back after the Charlie Kirk
murders. Okay, I think I'm I think I'm tracking that correctly
right now. Okay,
maybe maybe she'll just pull this up. It's getting a little squishy
in Wilmington, Delaware. I'm feeling claustrophobic in Wilmington,
Delaware, and I've never even been there. Okay, so here's our
block. We got a couple of blocks here, and we've told you yesterday,
we've got this FBI suite in this building that's actually owned
by the Wilmington Trust at 500 Delaware Avenue. We've got Breijit
Lawyers at 919 North Market Street. Also in that building happens
to be um Stacy Sheridan's registered agent. That's Stacy uh Sheridan
of Turning Point USA. We're going to talk about her in a second.
We've got the Wilmington Trust.
The best part about this is if you guys don't know like Delaware
it's I think it's zero tax incorporation or something right like
that there's a way to dodge corporate taxes like zero cost to
incorporate there and I think there's a way to dodge taxes in
Delaware that basically only exists in Delaware right so anyone
who runs any sort of large business has a presence in Delaware
in some way or another and in a lot of cases the real estate
is very small that you get there because you don't do your operations
in Delaware right you don't do your oper orations there. You
just have addresses there where you can receive mail for your
corporation because you want to incorporate in Delaware and privacy
for shareholders. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. So, like there's
a that would be the reason that all of these things like at least
the business owners would all be in this like area. They'd be
in like office space that's cheap and not even cheap, but it's
like over compressed, right? People I think a lot of these things
in some cases it's just like PO boxes. You basically just get
a PO box somewhere in Delaware, right? cross actual location.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Something along these lines me. It's
like you you have somebody who represents you in Delaware that
has like a whole bunch of stuff that they they receive a ton
of mail to the same >> 1100 North Market. We told you about
this cane uh this crane pardon. This red >> like if you
went to some of these places like if you went to where these
lawyers are and stuff, you might not find legal offices. You
might find like somebody who manages like incorporation or account
accounting for like big firms >> at 1100 North King Street.
That's brace bridge complex which is supposed to house insight
headquarters and they've got a French CEO. It's just a lot happening
here. And again now having a registered agent in Delaware isn't
you have an LLC supposed to have a registered agent. Uh and people
tend to choose between Wyoming and Delaware sometimes Las Vegas
to form their own corporations. But wow, what are the chances
that Casey Sheridan um has a registered agent that's in that
building too? Because I have LLC's and I have LLC's in uh in
Delaware and I'm not I'm not even in Wilmington. There's a lot
to choose from. It's a whole state. But Stacy Stace Sharon's
registered agent is there, too. People had noted, by the way,
that she had a few LLC's, uh, which she was getting paid through.
It could all be above board. I don't really know. But the one
I'm speaking about is Cloverstone Ventures. Stacy, by the way,
is the senior advancement director at Turning Point USA. She
was brought in specifically by Tyler Boyer to raise money and
to take Turning Point to the next level. And regarding Tyler
Ber, now we could say maybe a couple of weeks ago that he's a
criminal, but actually Donald Trump pardoned him. He pardoned
Tyler Boyer a couple of weeks ago, so we can't. That's actually
not real. He's um been pardoned, but he is always up to no good.
I can tell you that. And he brings in the Stacy Sheridan. I got
to tell you, I did not like >> Dude, the Trump pardons
are actually crazy, dude. Trump is in the middle of this naroterrorism
thing. And he pardons the guy, is it from Honduras, who's like
actually a a massive known drug dealer,
like somebody who actually probably ran tons of fentanyl into
the United States. >> Like her at all. Just the vibe was
>> what? How? How? I did not like her and I >> people
400 tons of >> Yes. 400 tons of
>> face when she was hired. That's when I kind of said
to him, you can't go down this path with money. Okay. Because
people that want to raise money and you're bringing people over
with the incentive of just wanting a lot of money, you can run
into trouble that >> Which is why I didn't feel great about
the fact that she was so involved after Charlie's assassination.
Stacy Sheridan is the one that was filming. Everyone's like,
"Who's filming his casket as it's being escorted off of Air Force
2?" Crying, holding that Stacy. Like I said, um I just felt spiritually
that Charlie hiring her was a mistake. She didn't pass my vibe
check. Suddenly, she's everywhere. She's eulogizing Charlie Kirk
on stage. She is capturing intimate photos of his casket. She's
then at the White House shedding tears over this fake holiday
that's been created. And I just want to solve actually who did
this. And the whole thing was making my skin crawl. If I'm being
honest, her involvement specifically made my skin crawl. I want
to say that openly.
So basically Candace is going to use this stream and the next
stream to totally like tear apart Turning Point USA to the point
that they start responding. So I think this is the second, right?
So her sec her stream on the second is not like as bad
her stream or I believe it's her stream. No, it's this stream.
She they get very uncomfortable with this stream. They actually
respond to this stream. Okay. So this is three days ago. Okay.
But she's there. Keeping timeline in mind she's there in this
squishy block. In this one block we are all just chilling Wilmington,
right? And we would have never gotten to this flock, by the way,
had it not been for the Egyptian planes. Us simply tracking >> dude.
Oh, it goes from this to Hold on, hold on, hold on. >> This
ties into Carol's content, too. Okay, that's the best part. And
I I just have not had the time. I'm reading a book right now
and I'm like really into it, so it's actually taking a ton of
my time. It's kind of unfortunate. I'm not even playing Civ.
I'm just like reading a book. >> Okay, so Ian Carol streams,
but he's live right now actually. But his streams recently have
been all on these Egyptian planes. Okay.
Military up. What are these flights? A mil What are the Were
these flights a military operation? Who really off Charlie Kirk?
Part one. Egypt, France, and Candace's assassination plot. Part
two. How is this all connected?
Getting a clearer picture. Part three. I made a calendar to make
sense of all these flights. Part three. What's Egypt's game?
Dude,
I realized that this is possible. No one can look at this. We
can't make sense of this. Like we can I can look at it and make
sense of it. Obviously, it's not like it's not impossible at
all to look at and make sense of, but it >> Oh, well that
was great. >> Ain't no way to make a video. It ain't no
way to communicate what's going on out here. >> And what
we need is calendar. We need a calendar of when were these very
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. This Oh, he's doing
it this way. Okay, this is not bad. This is actually critical,
though. Is like I want a way to be able to do like timelines
on stream and I feel like it would be good. That is actually
what I want to use Excalibur for. And I realize I've described
this before, but I think I can actually get into it at this point.
Okay. Is I want to go and do Excal or something to make like
timelines so I can have like a nice artifact from stream. I want
something like Okay. I want something kind of like
maybe a little bit like obsidian. A little bit, but not obsidian
cuz I don't want just a ton of notes. I want to be able to like
make something that I could the the ideal goal like the perfect
goal would be creating like an artifact on stream while you investigate
something that could be looked at by other people and be entertaining.
Now, that's incredibly difficult. It's hard to crystallize like
a thought process or what you like what relationships are between
things on the fly and have that be something that looks like
a finished product, but that would be the goal.
I'm just I'm looking through.
>> Dude, I do wonder what he figures out by the end of
this >> that we're talking about September 8th for the
group chat.
>> The northstar.com the text they hid Charlie Kirks. The
north
check how the flight patterns of these planes change since Charlie's
assassination. Thank you for the hours of work you're putting
in on this investigation for all of us. Ian, when FBI can't find
something, it's because they already know. I don't care how much
they try to stop this investigation. We must get to the bottom
of it no matter what. Dude, they've got everybody bought in.
Everyone bought in. They've all bought in. They got infinite
buy in on >> These Egyptian planes and somebody giving
us a tip like, "Hey, kind of >> By the way, every single
day Candace has streamed about this 150,000 views concurrent,
consistently
over and over and over again. 100 to 150,000 views concurrent.
>> Wilmington. And we go, "Aha, lights on." And here we
are. Right. We learn about this French and Israeli uh ACE partners
being the second largest shareholder of Satis. They decide to
lease out this hanger. We learn that that requires federal approval
because it sits on federal airways and maybe that means it requires
French approval. Who knows? Who knows? Um I don't know anything
at this point except everything stinks to high heaven. And so
I start asking myself, what do we all have in common? Why are
we all just chilling in Delaware? That's what I'm trying to ascertain.
What are we all doing over here near King Street? Who is the
king? Right? Do we have some shared interest that I haven't seen
through yet? And now would be the appropriate time for us to
get back into that timeline because there is an important question
that we forgot to ask. So let's jump into our timeline beginning
beginning with the inflection point which was that Tucker Carlson
speech. Now I want to say this on that July 11th when Tucker
Carlson gave that speech. I did and I hope I'm not betraying
anything too private here but I asked Tucker about that speech
like what what inspired you? I went back watched it and he's
he's going hard and he's talking about where's all this money
coming from and you know is this even a meritocracy America like
why are people that are not impressive billionaires what's happening
in this
>> bro what >> country I asked what made you say
that and he said I had no plan to say it just came out of my
mouth just it just like
>> I dude I >> was just inspired just came out of
my mouth when I hit >> Dude I can't I'm trying to figure
out I have to I play >> unfortunately Candace she She weaves.
Okay. She weaves kind of like Donald Trump does. So, I'm like
trying to figure out how to cut this down cuz I do have a lot
of content I want to get through to cover all this stuff, but
like she she weaves all over the place and it's so hard to figure
out what you can leave out. >> Charlie said goes Max and
that is what Tucker riffs and I I do think um that was a part
of there was something spiritual that moved him to say that.
I will say that. Anyway, so that's July 11. Tucker Carlson speaks
at Turning Point USA's conference and the donors freak out. Calls
out Jeffrey Epstein. He says that people who serve in foreign
armies should be stripped of their citizenship. he muses about
Bill Aman's wealth and where it comes from. We are told even
though we have not been able to confirm this with a shred of
evidence that it was 7 days later that the request came from
uh to turning point USA from UVU
chapter for Charlie to have this event. That's very late in the
day already but again we see no proof of this. We do know that
right after that our Egyptian yellow plane flies to Lincoln,
Nebraska and 2 days later it is announced in Nebraska that they're
going to be doing a trade and investment trip with Egypt. There
were some private off-record meeting that took place to make
this come to fruition and there were international professionals
that were there per the media. But who were these professionals
that met with Secretary of State Bob Evan? Why is this meeting
somehow off record? And when people and they have done that have
requested information, they say, "Oh, there's nothing that has
been that's public that we can share with you." Thank you to,
by the way, the citizens of Nebraska who did that. I received
your emails even if I was not able to respond. Anyways, then
uh it departs Nebraska, the our yellow planes, and it heads to
Wilmington and then it gets it goes back to Cairo.
We then know that in this same time frameish is when Charlie
vacations up to Maine for a couple of weeks to be with his family,
goes off radar. We've got Mikey McCoy and his wife uh Eliza that
joined them for the first time, first time they're doing this
joint family vacation. And Mikey's capturing these last videos
that are going to warm our hearts about Charlie. Uh and he's
like amazing. That's just how he is. And on July 25th, Charlie
speaks in Westchester, New York. >> Uh, what he's saying
there, Josh Kosh. Okay, you're asking Jay Sakun said, "What could
Candace say that these people say you're full of that these people
go and say back to her? You're full of is what he's asking."
Like literally, what would Candace have to say? Cuz it seems
like she keeps going totally crazy. There's like totally unrelated
stuff that's happening here. And what is the line? I dude, the
line is nothing. This is what she does. She basically, and again,
this is what it's so crazy that
you guys are going to say it's weird for me to connect it, but
her and Destiny do the same thing. It's just tone indicators
and saying, "I think this sensational thing. Here's a picture
of a cat. Here's a picture of a dog. Here's a picture of a mouse.
That's evidence of this thing." Right? Obviously, there's slightly
more tangentially related than that, but it's still all tangents,
right? It's not proving anything. uh these guys docks. Here's
the proof. Um they laughed about a joke at my expense and blah
blah blah and you do tone indicators. You say the conclusion,
you provide no evidence. You just say other facts and then people
go, "Where did I lie?" Well, you didn't lie. You just didn't
connect the things to prove what you said at all. Right? So that's
what Candace does is it'll be I know now that the French, okay,
the French helped in the assassination of Charlie Kirk. And how
do I know that? Well, it's because the French foreign legion
has has trained people. Um, the French government has assassinated
people before.
And also, the French government had an exercise like a month
before this in California. And then like a day, a week after
that in Minnesota, the French Foreign Legion did. And that's
how I know the French helped Charlie Kirk. But she doesn't say
that last part. She says, "I know the French Charlie Kirk." And
then she provides those couple of facts and then she'll go, "Tell
me where I lied. Tell me where I lied. It's been reported to
me that the French government had a hand in assassinating Charlie
Kirk. I didn't claim it. I just re-reported it. And here are
the facts. Here are some facts that are unrelated cuz she's getting
No, no, no, no. Pumpern nickel. No, no, no, no, no, no. Pumpern
nickel. You I This is This goes She's getting sued, but she was
going after them and doing this exact same thing. This is the
same strategy she employed with actually going after Bridget
Mcronone in the first place. Somebody else reported this fact,
but I'm saying it. I'm I'm saying somebody else reported this.
I'm not going to say it. I'm going to say somebody else reported
this. Here are some tangentially related things. French people
are French are in government suspiciously and Emanuel Mcron had
a book from a French offer author on his desk when he took his
first picture in his like office in Elizier Palace.
And that proves that Eman that Breit Mcronone without a doubt
was born a man. It's like, well, all of those things are facts,
but and and but it doesn't prove the thing she stated first.
No, no, no, no, no. I mean, she might be attaching this to it
for that reason, but she basically was saying that Charlie was
saying she was going to get assassinated or she thought she was
going to get assassinated and that she thinks Charlie was assassinated
for speaking the truth in some way, like she was supposed to
be as well. I have no [__] dude. It gets really It
gets really like we stretch a lot here. Okay, >> at the
end of July, this is a new uh a new little update for you. Why
Rei comes in as the number one sponsor of the Charlie Kirk fall
tour. So, this is end of July, early August. And I'm wondering
why they did that then, cuz that's pretty late in the day. Remember,
this was something they freaked out about when I said, "Hey,
this is not how Turning Point events are uh come together. They're
not instant actually uh in the history of me speaking on college
campuses and having headline these tours. They are planning them
at least a semester ahead." And then it was like mass panic.
I got like Lyla Rose and Ali Stucky who had never headlined their
tour suddenly saying that's not true, that's not true. What are
you talking about? And like I'm talking about I works there so
I know. >> How much of this is cynical versus delusional?
I mean if you think if you're asking how much of this is calculated?
A lot of it. Like basically all of it. Like she is calculating
that she can say these things and get away with it. And she doesn't
really think they're connected. She's basically just like in
her break tear down mode right now. But unfortunately it seems
like it doesn't matter. like she's just like the biggest creator
on YouTube right now. exactly what I'm talking about and that
was a weird thing to debunk and I'm wondering why was this put
together so late in the day and and I am musing here but I'm
wondering if why refi after Charlie lost millions of dollars
like again I will just say this is what shows you that unfortunately
like I'll go down with the democracy ship but democracy has failed
entirely right this is a totally this is a total absolute indicator
that democracy has failed entirely it cannot work it has failed
completely um people believe things with no basis people can
be made to believe things with no basis there is no way help
them. There's no way to pull them out. It's just over. It's like
you could be blackpilled on on democracy now until we like start
straight up taking authoritarian like you have to take authoritarian
control to fix it somehow. I think I think that's where you have
to go, right? You have to have somebody take control and say
like, "No, no, no. This can't be allowed to proceed anymore."
How do you determine the calculated versus delusional breakdown?
If she was delusional, she would say things that she could actually
get sued for way more often. That's what I'm telling you. Alex
Jones. Alex Jones opened himself up to defamation all of the
time, right? Like he constantly opened himself up to defamation.
He could have been sued by so many people for defamation. Candace
very rarely does. Candace is very calculated in how she says,
"Actually, this is what somebody told me. Actually, this is what
I've heard. Look, we had a chatter who said this. Look, I'm just
reading a chatter message. Look, I'm just reading a YouTube comment.
Look, I'm just reading an email I got."
>> Said, "Hey,
you can make that up by going on tour." you know, like we we
were willing to do this and maybe Charlie actually wasn't planning
on going on tour at all and this tour actually came together
very quickly. I'm musing on that. I I'm not introducing that
as a fact. I'm introducing that as a a question. Anyways, back
to our timeline where Rei is going big and they are are going
to be uh the main sponsor of this fall tour. And uh that's how
that came together. Then we know that in very early August Turning
Point was scouting uh that location and that event. and they
specifically requested for Charlie to be in that amphitheater.
Now, apparently Charlie had done uh according to some insiders
had had loved an event that he had done in >> Okay, so
they specifically requested for Charlie to be in that amphitheater
>> amphitheater environment in Nashville, but I don't know
if he said, "I only want to do that going forward." But I do
know that Turning Point USA insisted upon that. The person that
was orchestrating um that event, Macy Macy Crofts, was is saying,
"Look, this is what Charlie wants." And that could be true. Uh
August 2nd is when we have our French legionnaires arriving in
America for a three-week training session in California, which
is going to end on the 25th. And then a couple days later, we
had that the Hampton's retreat, which Charlie Kirk himself described
as an intervention, as an Israel intervention. And influencers
who were there said that he was being pressed on his shifting
viewpoints on Israel. And we know that the influencers were paid
for by Bill Aman. I don't think that that's particularly a big
deal. Obviously, he has interests and was potentially coming
out as donor USA. We have what I do think is a big deal, which
is BB Net and Yahoo calling Charlie and offering to take Turning
Point to the next level. And that, my friends, is the billion-dollar
question, maybe the trillion dollar question in exchange for
>> Do you actually believe Candace's podcast influencing
how or uh influencing how ordinary people act politically? Sorry.
What do you think I'm saying when I say it shows that democracy
doesn't work? Only mute. What do you think I'm saying?
So, I'm I'm telling you that people can't critically evaluate
information. They're incapable. and that there are certain things
that you can just dig into in people's brains. There's like certain
primal things you can do content on where they are going to basically
just like believe you and get amped and get like on your side.
And if people don't have like dignity or principles or pride
or values, they will do these things and they will totally rip
people's brains.
>> And that's what Candace Owens does. She just like totally
rip people's brains.
She's actually very good at it. I'm very shocked. I I kind of
thought she sounded dumb a lot of the time, but I don't know.
I've been sort of immunized against it. Um, the problem with
democracy is literally that 50% of the population is below 100
IQ. Uh, that's not the only problem with democracy.
That's not the only problem. The real problem with democracy,
like capital liberal democracy, is that eventually you get enough
smart people who are willing to
It's not just that. There's a lot of problems. That's not the
only problem. Dumb people aren't the only problem. >> Have
we considered that? >> I wish dumb people were the only
>> 24 war and he he calls >> No, it's like it's like
there are just eventually
eventually there's a massive incentive and eventually you the
the conditions get created such that people can concentrate wealth
in a way that basically like a ton of people are cut out that
they have no more incentive to participate in the system. Eventually,
this this system will concentrate wealth through technology,
right? At this point, I think we're reaching like a technological
liftoff point where you will no longer have the ability for like
a regular person to get into the get onto like the wealth ladder
in the same way it's always been in the same way it's been since
like for forever basically for the entirety of American history
so far.
Like it's it's basically going to totally it's going to be totally
different I think. And I don't know what that looks like going
forward. It's um yeah, as labor becomes not valuable, as your
the work of your hands becomes not valuable. It's like technically,
Yeah. I I don't know. It's happening more rapidly than I expected
it to happen. Or it feels like it's happening more rapidly than
I expected it to >> Kirkin asks, you know, do you want
to come to Israel? We can take turning points to the next level
in exchange for what and through who? Because I'm going to guess
that Netanyahu is not just >> Is that her? Is that me?
>> Check sign Yahoo. And uh >> that's me. Hold on,
hold on, hold on. This window is
hold on hold on hold
>> just do that as an act of charity the next level
>> and that my friends is the billion dollar question maybe
the trillion dollar question >> back to it >> in
exchange for what
have we considered that this man is fighting like an war and
he he calls Charlie Kirk and asks you know do you want to come
to Israel we can take turning points to the next level in exchange
for what and through who because I'm going to guess that BB Netanyahu
is not just going to write a check signed by Netanyahu and uh
just do that as an act of charity in exchange for what? What's
he going to take turning point to a next level? This is something
that nobody has denied took place. No one has denied that that
this took place and Charlie declined.
Charlie declined that offer. So, what that signals to me is that
Charlie then had information um about maybe how they move money,
right, without registering for FAR? Um I don't know. I think
that's a big question that needs to be asked. Let's keep going.
>> Charlie declined money from Bill Aman. What did he know
about the GPS? I guess I guess
immediately
10 days later
our planes come back out and they're flying to Lincoln.
>> 20 years Silicon Valley will look like Mordor with Peter
Teal's giant flaming eye watching all the homeless people living
in huts below.
Uh
I don't know if it's like quite that d I my bigger problem is
I think
to me it seems obvious that we're at like an inflection point
where if something doesn't change your labor will be devalued.
You will have no ability to fight back. You'll have no ability
to like um take back any of your value as a person.
And as people become as like there will be a breaking point where
people realize that they've been devalued and they go to fight
back in some way metaphorically or literally. And that's my concern.
Like when when people tell you we can make America better, we
can make we can fix the economy. We can make it. No, you're they're
lying to you. They're totally lying to you. Your labor will always
be devalued from here on with the current paradigm.
Your labor will always be further devalued. It will always go
down. It's not going to get better, right? And
>> I think what I would say is I think at this point there's
still a decent chance at like a democratic solution that doesn't
totally like
that's not revolutionary, that's not violent in some way, but
you're going to find it crazy how fast people flip from being
like, "Oh, I'm I totally believe in capitalism. I totally believe
in I I totally believe in capitalism."
to Oh, actually, no. I'm a communist and we need to seize the
means of data center production. Okay.
The AI robot dogs. Robot dogs, bro. It's already over for us.
I don't think so. Luxury communism is the dreams of all futurists,
but it seems it will only be possible for the elite. Well, well,
well. It's not even like luxury. Like, things aren't going to
degrade fast enough. I think I don't think things degrade fast
enough for it to be like that bad that quickly. But again, I
just look at who is talking about it. It was um Oh, I didn't
reset the subs before the stream. God damn it.
I didn't reset the subs and we got a couple subs here.
It's Man, Coalition governments and countries that are more socialist
seem to be pretty resilient in terms of what can still be democratic.
Maybe. I don't know if you can tax your way out of this. I don't
know. I don't know, man. I don't
[__]
Five subs or more. Um, oh, are you saying for more time on the
stream? Wait, how long do we have? Let me see here. We got an
hour 30. I think we've got one sub in. So, whatever it is on
top of that. Yeah, we got one sub in for for the day. Give me
a second. I'll reset that.
Like, in my mind, labor is consistently being devalued. Like,
consistently being devalued over and over again. And if if you
have a free market, the free market will never value that labor
the same way, right? But I see a bunch of politicians who are
continuing to say like, "We can fix it. We can fix it. We can
fix it." And then they don't do anything that can fix it. They're
like, "Actually, we need to maximalize or we need to maximize
like our like our advant we need to take advantage of the free
market more. We need to get rid of regulation." It's like, "Dude,
what what are you talking about? What need a reading material
on this?" Well, I don't even know if anybody's talking about
it. I'm I'm talking about like a feeling I
Um I don't even know. I don't even know where I'd go to find
people talking about how labor is currently being devalued. The
answer is embracing population decline and using everything to
increase productivity of the remaining labor force. But that's
what they'd argue they're doing,
right? That's what they'd argue they're doing. Only commute.
The issue is nobody there is no way to Well, I understand technofudism.
I understand that argument. I'm saying I don't know who's talking
about this from like a positive
So
again, you can increase the productivity of remaining labor,
but what every country is doing is they're bringing in tons of
immigrants, right?
>> And increasing the productivity of of existing labor.
Hold on. Thank you very much, Cam, for the gifted sub.
So they're they're bringing in a lot of immigrants to try to
offset the population decline and increasing the value of labor
incre increasing the productivity and people are finding that
they can cut workers to increase profits or to incre like make
their companies more profitable. And I'm saying that if that's
true and you have like this capital that lets you, you know,
pay for AI and offsets a lot of your white labor costs, which
I'm still dubious of in a lot of ways, right?
Then how in the world do you enter that property ladder if your
labor as a single person is being continuously de like devalued,
right?
>> Cuz realistically, it feels like most corporations are
cutting their biggest expense, which is usually your labor costs,
right? that that feels like the way people are maintaining profits
right now, the way they're maintaining their balance sheets is
they're just cutting labor over and over again. And there's probably
there's like two outcomes there. Either like you are going to
be able to
either you're going to be able to offset that successfully with
AI and other optimizations
or you're cutting your labor costs in a way that's unsustainable
for your business and your business is slowly going to tank and
we're going to see like total economic devastation. Yeah, exactly.
Marty is basically
are getting the necessary productivity they need out of fewer
workers
they just don't need more humans to do more work, more busy work.
Like the only solution is to boycott companies that are too AI
integrated.
Um then they'll just start hiding it or they'll be doing something
right now like they sorry they'll be doing something to obfiscate
it. I don't know that like
Yeah, Marty, I don't know how much you like I don't know how
much you agree or disagree with this. This feels like it's just
obvious on its face to me. Going to need UBI eventually. Well,
everybody has somehow been brainwashed against UBI working ever.
That's the sad thing. Um, did you know that current GDP growth
would be flat or negative if not for AI capex investment? Yes,
I did know that. I think that one's way more common to know that
basically the the capex on AI right now is basically all growth
in the United States. They're just building data centers over
and over again. The sad thing is or the weird thing is is it
seems like they're they're pouring tons of money into it and
I'm not sure that I quite see yet
where the real true tangible wins are. Like
I get it makes some things more productive, but what is it automating?
What is it making more productive?
>> What is it making better? Thank you for the five gifted
as well. I think that's definitely another hour on the stream
at
2 hours 255 57.
I dude, it feels weird, but like should I use perplexity to look
up where AI efficiency is coming in? Hold on. What is this video?
Give me a second. I'm looking for basically
I'm not I'm not looking for a video right now. I'm looking for
anything that's showing me the JTO cover this Nero Milo saying
some I'm looking for anything that's showing me the real like
gains made by AI 2026 year is the year of the Fentes gay tape
comes out because that's the year I'm dropping it. Uh if he by
the way if he had this he would have dropped it at some point
he was getting brutally raped by Fentes
like I that would have happened you know what I'm saying like
probably any of the times he was getting brutally raped by Fentes
publicly would have done that if he had it. I just don't think
he has it. Feels pretty unlikely, you know. Anyway, yep, yep,
yep, yep, yep, yep, yep. That feels like what it is is basically
all these people have decided anything featuring complex forecasting
is improved with AI in supply chains where we need to allocate
scarce resources. See, this is like machine learning. This is
like a this is like an optimization problem. Is is that AI? Is
there like I don't I don't think that's AI in the same way that
it's like like it's not an LLM you're feeding that into, right?
Like an AI to me is like an LLM
That's like you're describing like machine learning which is
a very different thing. There's no like there's no nothing approximating
intelligence there.
Okay. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry. We'll call machine learning like a field of AI. Absolutely.
But I'm I'm not talking about like something that's like I think
the current buildup the current like AI capex is going towards
um
trying to build up something that approximates like human thought
creativity trying to build towards like an AGI
and I'm just not I'm not sure that this
are there like professionals who work on AI who believe who work
on LLMs and stuff AI is more than LLM? No, it's not. I'm okay
here's the thing. It is. But when I'm talking about AI from like
an economic investment standpoint,
is there are there Okay, this would be another question. Are
there significant things that aren't stable diffusion or some
like diffusionesque process or an LLM which I mean stable diffusion
might be an LLM?
Are those are those running through the same models and are those
getting investment from open AI and these other places because
chat GPT is an LLM and that's where a ton of the investment is
going through sorry open AI right and like through chat for chat
GPT okay so that's what I was looking for Marty is basically
the people who are investing in AI AI are all talking about uh
LLM yes okay
you have to look now but here's a paper from 2024 on the devaluation
of labor specifically essential work okay dude why are you not
asking it well I That's why I just laughed. I was like, can I
ask perplexity? Hey, can you show me like a study that shows
AI like making real productivity games for people? Cuz the idea
I get is that it basically what AI does is you've automated out
like your emails. You basically have automated responding to
emails. You use like chat GPT to do your emails for you. And
then basically none of like the real work you do is effectively
like made a lot easier through AI. Right now, unless you're like
an artist or I think like the art stuff, it seems like there's
tangible things happening. Okay. yard stuff feels very real
um to me, right? Like I've I've But that's because I know Top
Bronson. Top Bronson is doing like really cool stuff where he
he cranks these avatars out in like 20 minutes, 30 minutes,
right? So I think I think that's really cool
programming too obviously. So I think there's a lot of aspects
of programming that are helped a lot by it like all of the um
you talk about what was it? Vibe coding and stuff like that.
There are aspects of programming for rapid prototyping that are
massively helped by AI. Yes, absolutely. He uses AI, right? Yes,
you can actually program. You can ask for almost anything you
want.
Oh, yeah, I know. Yeah, I the vibe coding stuff seems pretty
cool. Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure. It's very good for this evil as
well. Evil Johnny Bravo. Like if you the thing is is probably
what you're doing I what I think AI does for people who program
is it gives people who would have been able to program very easily
the ability to use to to like program things for themselves.
Like if you have a a thought process where you're capable of
abstraction and capable of like distilling problems down probably
with through AI you can code things. Um, this is what I've this
is what I've seen even less using like uh co-pilot or I think
I used I used like the Jet Brains model whatever they were doing
for a while. I think I subscribed for that and I just found that
like oh I can actually like code like I can jump into some other
language or grab some framework and just start coding cuz I'm
like here's what I want and then basically it starts like spitting
stuff out for you becomes very easy. It's also a good abstraction
over Stack Overflow. Yeah. Well, that's what it is, damners.
But I'm telling you that
what you need to do is you need to be you need to be able to
know how to solve your problems, right? Or or like what your
problem is and identify what your problem is, and then you can
get it to like solve it for you. Realistically, like a lot of
a lot of programming is it comes down to like identifying your
problem, what you what you want to do, what you have to do, and
then writing it is at least for me anyway, writing it was like
the least of my problems. You know what I'm saying?
I used to I used to joke with people that I like wouldn't code.
I'd like think about how to solve stuff. I I'd sit at my desk
a lot and I just like think and then people would be like, "Dude,
you you're like the laziest." I'm like, "Bro, I have way more
commit. I I pushed a prod way more than you. [__]
off." Right? And then I'd say I'm like Michelangelo. Do you guys
ever hear about Michelangelo?
Michelangelo would like stare at a block of marble for a long
time and then he would just carve out in like one long exhaustive
process his entire sculpture. He'd like he'd like do it in his
brain. That's what I'd tell people. I'm like Michelangelo. Okay.
Yeah. I'm sitting here. Yeah. I'm like just kind of like twiddling.
I'm like spinning a pen while thinking. Okay.
I'm spinning a pen while thinking.
most of the time I was not I was not doing anything. I was not
doing it. I was literally just being a lazy [__]
and they were calling me out. Okay. I was not like Michelangelo.
I was not like Michelangelo at all. I I did a lot of I did a
lot of the thing where you like didn't work as much at work and
then you'd make up like an hour or two after work because you
didn't actually work at work. I'd end up doing that a lot.
But damn, I look cool. Okay, I push prod all the time. Kind of
were you working on? Absolute slop web apps. Josh Kosh, thank
you for asking. Absolute slop web apps. I get to do some cool
backend stuff sometimes, but
um
like backend
stuff for slop web apps. Okay, the exact thing AI automated out.
I've done more than that. I've done like actual systems coding
and stuff. I could easily go pick up like I'm I'm very proficient
at picking up like low-level languages and stuff. Written a lot
of stuff in low-level languages. Wrote an operating system in
college, but I like I just I don't know if I'll ever get back
into it. Will you look at my list interpreter when I finish soon?
Yeah, maybe. You want to show me your code? Sure, sure, sure.
Cool. Backend stuff equals dumb APIs. No, I did some cool I did
some actual cool stuff
like not just not writing APIs only. But I did like when I say
dumb web app stuff, it was a lot of API stuff, but I I got to
actually do some cool [__] Just some like architectures
and stuff for I don't
I don't know. cool stuff at one point. But anyway,
>> we should probably continue on with the Canada stuff.
Although the where are we going with the AI conversation? I think
substance leaked me some stuff on labor devaluation.
Like this would just be very interesting to look into cuz I find
I find like it's easy to think of like trivial solutions like
if you say like oh well we need to boycott like AI. It's like
well that probably just leads to China making the dominant AI
that takes over the planet, right? So I don't know. Is it like
an arms race? Is are we in the middle of like the nuclear arms
race right now? I don't know, man. It's sketchy. It's scary.
It's concerning. Okay, I just wanted to go open up that article
substance link me so I don't lose it.
Oh, I and I didn't. God damn it. Hold on. Scroll back in this
chat a little bit. There we go. Got it now. Okay, good, good,
good, good, good, good, good. Okay, let's uh let's continue with
this. I prefer China's AI to the monopolized AI we're getting
from the big guys. Um, isn't hold on. Isn't uh Facebook doing
AI in a cool way with Llama? Isn't Llama like an open model totally?
Like all of their stuff's open all over the place?
Isn't that like a part of their core mission
statement?
Well, this hold on. This is my thing, Josh Kosh, is I I think
personally
I just want to know what a bunch of experts think about whether
or not LLMs are the paradigm that gets you to AGI or if they're
too limited. if there's like a theoretical like what are the
theoretical limits or what do people think are the theoretical
limits and are we already at like the optimization stage where
we're really never getting past this I don't know how it's I
don't know how it's scaling still also I'll be right back give
me two seconds >> are going to Wilmington they stay for
one night Charlie speaks in South Carolina we have our yellow
planes then returning on the 24th again always through Wilmington
to Egypt we then have our French legionnaires have completed
their training and on August 24th 27th operation Balhalla takes
place between civilian Ians and military men in Minnesota at
Camp Ripley.
Uh then we have the first public sign that went out on August
27th. August 27th is so late in the day uh to begin promoting
an event. TB USA, UVU, and a local BYU chapter share a graphic
announcing that Charlie is coming to UVU. But there are no location
details mentioned on that graphic. So still not full details,
but at least the first announcement goes out. On the 29th, we
have Operation Brightar which commences. That joint operation
that we told you about which is bienial between Egypt and the
United States military and other countries are coming together.
And it is being reported that is going to run through to September
10th. On September 2nd, Charlie sends out the email asking for
a Doge audit of his company, and he announces that Justin Strife
is going to be the new COO taking over for Tyler Boyer, who was
the COO. And then we have
the first known public going out in local media. >> We
can skip to the next section. You should know that Candace was
being insanely conspiratorial, okay, insanely conspiratorial
about Turning Point USA. It's kind of all you need to know unless
she's proven correct, which she's not going to be because obviously
I've gone everything I've gone through with Candace. Here's the
thing. Even if I go through everything Candace has gone has said,
I see nothing that actually ties into proving a point that she's
trying to claim or saying somebody else claimed. Right? That's
the issue. She's showing me a whole bunch of facts that don't
actually lead to anything.
She like Tazo's DMs in ISIS Discord, but then deleted them when
she realized it proved the opposite of her point. Yikes. But
anyway, so with with Candice, like even if this all came out
is true, it's like, well, why did you not prove it in any way
then? Why did you like literally do nothing to prove it? Be very
concerning. Be very weird. >> Going to take place in the
courtyard. That's on September. Okay. >> On September 4th,
our planes come in and we know um what happens next. Charlie
is in Korea for a couple of days. He comes back on September
10th and he gets assassinated. And that's also happens to be
the same day that that Operation Bright Star at Cairo joint operation
formally ends. Okay. So, so she's like introduced this operation
bright star thing in Cairo is something that happens every year
and it ends on September 10th. What does that mean? What does
that matter? Why is that relevant to anything? She doesn't connect
it in any way except that they're like Egyptian planes that leave
Wilmington, Delaware.
BTT departed Wilmington, Delaware for Cairo at 7:56 a.m. local
time.
BTT departed Provo, Utah at Oh, so here's here's where it is.
Okay, this is the thing. There's a plane that goes from Provo,
Utah,
and I guess lands. This must be BTT. It must be the same plane,
right? So then it goes from Utah to Wilmington and then from
Wilmington to Cairo. >> So that wait to Paris then back
home to >> That Cairo joint operation formally
>> Okay. So that timeline makes me uncomfortable. Okay.
It makes me very uncomfortable and I'm wondering if Charlie put
together the doge account and I want to be clear this part of
speculation because something that he maybe learned when he asked
take it to the next level made him think maybe I should look
through turning points finances like where is this money coming
in from and where is it going and I don't know that for a fact
but I think it's a fair question a fair investigative question
is what inspired Charlie to suddenly be concerned about not just
where the money was going but where the money was coming from
was an offer made to him that he declined yes what was that offer
for in exchange
and I want to say this Charlie said no Charlie died with his
soul intact. Dying with his soul intact. He said no. He said
no to a lot of money. >> But it was actually a tip that
I received early on that pulled everything together for me in
a really dark way. It >> Oh,
she's going to tie it all together. All right. She's going to
make it all >> water cooler talk.
>> Oh, also, uh, it's water cooler talk from another source.
I didn't say it. I'm just telling you what they said. I'm not
saying it. I'm just telling you what they said. Immediately after
Charlie's assassination, a few people had signified and were
speculating and thinking about things that were weird. And you
know, I told you we had so many people from Turning Point USA
that were just venting in our tip box and telling us that they
didn't like the way management was acting and things were weird
and there were just a flurry of things that were coming in. And
a few of them had signified that one of the things that were
one of the things that was being whisper whispered about that
people thought was quite odd that they learned that happened
on the day of assassination was a rumor pertaining to Justin
Strife.
an odd an oddly placed phone call uh that he made almost immediately
as they say. This is alleged. It wasn't on the phone call after
Charlie was
>> there's an anonymous source that is alleged that said
a phone call happened between somebody at Turning Point USA who
I've never heard of. Okay. And it's very concerning.
Just to set it up, this is why I don't think it's delusion. This
is why I don't think it's like uh like her just being schizophrenic
because she will consistently try to set things up as if like
I'm just reporting things that were said publicly somewhere or
or were sent to me over email. They're just tips. I can't verify
them. I don't know the veracity, but I'm going to say all of
>> And I will say allegedly because there's six people
at Turning Point USA who have >> now you can do that sometimes
if you like say true things at other times, right? But the issue
is she doesn't say true things at other times. She just does
this a 100% of the time.
>> 100% of the time. It's every single time. It's like
somebody else made this claim and I'm just talking about it.
>> Um that we're talking about this. This rumor got passed
around. They said that Justin had placed an immediate call to
a donor prospect. And I said that's weird. Okay. I'd like to
know more about that. Can everybody try to figure out what donor
that was? Now, it's possible it could have just been a very close
donor friend. Charlie had them. He did. There were some donors
that he loved like family members. And so that was a potential
longshot thing, but just interesting. I'd like to know who he
was so close to that required an immediate call. Then it it turns
out that these ladies told me that this donor actually uh had
a a pretty big piece of bait on the hook for Turning Point USA,
a piece of their billion dollar company. They were anticipating
um some IPO and that this was going to be lifechanging
money. Okay, we're not talking like, oh, a check that's going
to be reeled in for $5 million or $10 million or $50 million
or like the $90 million that Turning Point USA raised in the
first couple of weeks following Todd's assassination.
We are talking like billionaire money,
uh, potentially billions of dollars. And this was a very big
secret, a huge secret.
Just a handful of people were allowed to even know about this,
that this was happening. In fact, there's probably people that
are watching this right now at Turnpoint USA who work in donations.
It's a pretty large department that have no idea. I've never
even heard of this because that's how incredibly top level secret
this was. >> This is like super secret. Okay. So, just
cuz you work in Turning Point USA's financing or finance or accounting
department doesn't mean that you'd know about it. Okay. >> Okay.
But people began to find out about this because of just an unfortunate
conversation that had been left unattended to. Okay.
Now, why was the secret supposed to be so guarded? Why is this
person getting a phone call? I I wanted to know. I wanted to
know more. and I start messaging our >> One thing I should
learn from Candace, okay, is her deliveries, I think, do get
people reeled in.
Now, why would we think this? Now, why why would somebody go
and do this? Exactly. Well, I'm going to tell you. Well, why
would why would this happen? It's like uh it is somebody said
it earlier. It's like um it's like true crime, but you never
find anything out. It's the true crime cadence, right? Now, why
Now, why exactly
would Erica Kirk do this? Why exactly would would Charlie Kirk
tell me
that he didn't want to do this? Like, I think I think I could
learn something from this cadence. There's probably a less gay
way to sound, but still get the same effect. I'll have to figure
it out. Okay. Or maybe that's the reason only women are successful
in true crime podcast or podcasts.
you know, >> mommy slooh and our daddy slew and all of
my sources at Turning Point USA and I'm saying anything that
you can tell me about this in case this might be important. And
I got an answer on the name of a donor and I had completely forgotten
because again this happened so early following the assassination.
I am talking before I even went to Wyoming. My brain was still
traumatized. I had so much information I was trying to process
while I was grieving that I literally forgot the big part that
I learned about this donor. I forgot. And these young women told
me that this donor was French
and that this donor's name was Pierre.
It wasn't until yesterday after we went off air that I presented
to you all of this stuff about the Dupont family.
Oh my god,
it's a Dupont.
Um that it clicked and these ladies messaged me and said, "Oh,
you figured it out. It's Pierre Dupont." question mark exclamation
point question mark exclamation point I had mentioned Pierre
on yesterday's show and um
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh the thing evil Johnny
bra that you're saying here really quickly just about the LLM
again is I do think they are going to integrate advertising in
a way that will be profitable for them. Yes, I think it will
be they're they're basically now I think looking to upend Google
as search. They would like to they I think they're seeing themselves
as like search and they're going to try to overtake the search
market
that like basically when you open your phone you go to type something
in search is what you have to like search is the biggest thing.
I thought chat GPT already has ads. No no no no no no no no.
like prioritizing answers like I'm looking for the best this
>> This took my breath away. I will be honest. I was I
cried really hard yesterday thinking
my goodness, how could I have forgotten that this donor
was French, French American, that that was the big thing. And
I was racking my brain trying to figure out that time because
I hadn't even considered France's involvement in anything. like
who do I know that's French and has tons of money and is involved
in and in technologies and could possibly be working on a big
check that could be kept secret because it's about to IPO and
billions are on the line and and it all kind of came together
and I I would like an answer about this Pierre the billionaire
French American donor and I would like a clean answer as to whether
or not it is Mr. Pierre Dupont. Yeah, because this would be a
dark story.
And my sources are very sure, very sure that this is what was
on the line, that this was life-changing money. And um they are
very sure that this individual got a phone call after the assassination.
And I think that we deserve to know. I don't think it should
be a secret, right? Charity shouldn't be a secret. Why? And by
the way, it leads to more questions like how could you?
>> Okay, so it's just like a random person here, I guess.
like a random person.
Not random, not totally random, but like she's tying in the French
stuff, the dupants, and oh, what it's like her whole conspiracy,
it's like everything ties together. She's managed to tie everything
together. It all centers around her. She is like the truth teller
who is disturbing like the the one world order, okay, that is
going to that's going to take everything over that that controls
everything already. You say that you knew that your IPO was going
to lead to billions of dollars. How could you promise that? How
could you promise that? And did Charlie know? Did Charlie know?
And I'm going to be honest with you, I know a lot of billionaires,
they don't part with their money like that. They don't part with
their money and offer people parts, pieces of their company,
people that aren't even their family members. So why was that
offer on the table? I have so many. Didn't she say, "Oh, hold
on. Black tarpet, you're behind." Okay. So, what happened is
the president of France is trying to kill her and France was
directly is now directly implicated in the assassination of Charlie
Kirk. Okay. And Bridget Mcronone is putting out a hit on her
probably with the same people who killed Charlie Kirk. It's like
all blending together. All of this stuff is becoming one conspiracy.
She's taking her getting sued by the Mcron and saying Turning
Point USA was complicit in Charlie Kirk's assassination. and
she's blending them into the same conspiracy.
>> Many questions and I'm going to ask them publicly and
I think that we demand answers. We should all be demanding answers
because this is now starting to >> but don't worry um we're
going to get actually some kind of satis something that approaches
a satisfying conclusion. >> Very very >> not conclusion
but satisfying in terms
turning point basically says, "Okay, Candace, we're ready to
talk. We're going to have a talk."
and her actions after that point are hilarious.
>> It's too French, right? It's just too French. We just
can't all be hanging out in Delaware.
And there's one more thing that came in regarding uh Andrew Kovette.
Very close family friend of Andrew Kovette had messaged me uh
early on and I again was not tracking any of this at the time,
but they had said that they felt that Andrew Kovette was acting
weird and I'm sure that's not a big deal. I think we were all
acting weird. Felt assassinated. Moreover, they had mentioned
that specifically
Andrew had told them that when Charlie said no to BB, he lost
out on millions. Now, I'm going to say allegedly because this
is a tip, but I have it in writing. I'm not lying to you. And
I thought to myself, that's so weird. How could the spokesperson
at Turning Point USA be on the How could they be gaining millions
from that? What's the what is the what is the structure here
with these contracts that even people that are in PR, people
that are like running PR departments are getting tips on the
basis of donations? I don't know how this is working, but we
need to figure out how this is working. I think I think it's
really important that we that we learn the truth about what happened.
Who's Pierre? Is it Pierre Dupont? And has Turning Point been
paid. Obviously, it wouldn't be on this year's taxes. You're
not going to find those on on this year's taxes, but they would
be on next year's, but we can ask now. And I'm asking now, and
there's more I want to share, but we're going to take a brief
break for sponsors. I'll ask the question. What do you Candace?
>> Dude, she just did the same delivery for her announcing
her like sponsors. Hold on. There's more that I want to share,
but now we're going to take the break.
>> Responsors obviously. >> See, she can't get rid
of the delivery. The delivery has become a part of her.
>> There is such a thing as a good fed. Believe it or not,
there are good guys. There are good guys everywhere. You know,
lightness is always fighting darkness. And I received an interesting
tip from a fed that I'm going to share with you now that might
be relevant. But Turning Point USA put in a personal request
to try to get the Egyptian plane
And I find that to be very interesting. I find that to be very
interesting. What is it about these Egyptian planes that Turning
Point USA didn't want them to be
>> So, how exactly did they put in a request for this to
get?
Candace has like a bribes at
If you need something, just send me money here. >> I don't
know. Uh, but I am going to find out. I think we kind of have
found out in a weird really effed up way actually. It makes my
stomach turn. I'm going to miss Charlie. I really am going to
miss Charlie. And I think when Charlie was assassinated, there
was something about it. I knew that the story was going to be
dark instantly. I knew that Charlie was betrayed. They laughed
at me. Oh, you had a dream. Charlie told you he was Yeah, Charlie
told me that he was betrayed. And I think part of the more >> She
just straight up says it.
That's actually so awesome. How do you How did you first figure
out that Charlie was betrayed? He came to me in a dream. He came
to me in a dream and he let me know.
>> She just said yes. Hold on. She just said it. find that
to be very interesting. What is it about these Egyptian planes
that turning point USA didn't want them to be discussed? I don't
know. Uh but I am going to find out. I think we kind of found
out in a weird really way. Actually, it makes my time turn. I
really am going to miss Charlie. And I think when Charlie was
assassinated, there was something about it. I knew that this
story was going to be dark instantly. I knew that Charlie was
betrayed. They laughed at me. Oh, you had a dream. Charlie told
you he was Yeah, Charlie told me that he was betrayed. And I
think >> in a dream he told you he was betray in a dream
she watched her friend get assassinated and went on a dream journey
and within the dreamscape Charlie Kirk came to her and said Candace
I was betrayed also it was the also it was the French also
I wanted to be a Catholic the whole time. Goodbye Candace.
part of the morning was
>> dude. Charlie shared a lot of things with her in that
dream. Okay. >> I was experiencing was in large part due
to my understanding that this was going to be missional for me.
I knew I think I knew deep down that this was going to be missional.
And I kind of knew deep down that the whole world was going to
be against me or I guess the whole dark apparatus was going to
be against me. Not the world. There are so many good people in
the world that are the reason I'm doing this and who understood
instantly and felt instantly what I felt when this all happened.
And I think it's sad because I was just reflecting on I guess
really the last part of my youth being ignorant and thinking
that we lived in a country that was free and was fair and was
a meritocracy. The excitement of me and Charlie in politics like
we were young bucks thinking that we were going to change the
world because the MAGA movement offered us this opportunity to
do it right. We are going to get Trump elected and we're going
to get people to stop talking about racism and to understand
like family is a priority. And and I realize now and I know Charlie
realizes now that we did not see the evil that was around us.
And I'm going to miss that youth. You know what I mean? I'm going
to miss that young experience. I'm going to miss Charlie going
on dates and the girl they liked and me always being the w. >> Oh
no, don't do this one. Oh, this one's >> Woman and him
asking. And I this text message is my one of my favorite text
messages between me and Charlie when he was getting ready to
go on a date and you know he didn't date many people and he was
just kind of in love with this girl and >> uh this upset
a lot of people. Okay, this upset a bunch of people. Okay. Um
because she basically is like talking about him dating a girl
that's not his wife. You know what I'm saying?
Like he she's talking about him dating a girl who's not his wife.
And that just upset a lot of people in these right-wing movements.
>> He's asking, "Should I wear this?" And this is the text
messages. >> Oh, also also to be clear, they're talking
about when they were younger. They're Candace is talking about
like 10 years ago. Just to be clear, I I know she's like 35 now.
She's talking about like 10 years ago when they were young, not
like recent. This is like goober Charlie. Okay. This is Charlie
Kirk so long ago. He hadn't gained the weight that made his facial
facial features seem quite so tiny on his face. Honestly, the
tiny face Charlie Kirk is better though because this is off-putting.
I will be honest. Without the tan, without whatever, I don't
know, whatever he had going on recently. This is like a little
offputting. No, he doesn't look normal. It's the angle that makes
him look normal. He looks like a straightup alien from the front.
Okay. >> Sweet. He said, "Do I have to change this shirt?"
And I wrote back, "Yes, and throw it away if you can."
>> Little bit Xanderhol coded. Yes. >> Heh, okay.
And he's wearing a Turning Point early shirt that somebody I
think gave to me stitched. Honestly, is it stitched on? Is it
on your I don't know. But I was like, Charlie, burn it. Obviously,
burn that shirt. And it makes me um Yeah, this is something that
makes me cry and makes me sad because he just was so young. You
know, Charlie was so young and he was such a good person. And
I'm also going to miss
>> I will say when now she's talking about now he was so
young. I do think there's something really okay not in this case
specifically as much um because I do think Charlie Kirk was working
towards goals that were very bad but in a lot of probably in
this case too it does suck that somebody who was willing to put
all of their work in that worked so hard and built something
for themselves and their family has their life cut short before
they get to ever retire and enjoy that. That feels like kind
of up to me. It's it it is Charlie Kirk and I do think he's working
towards very very like basically evil goals. But it's very sad
that somebody worked so hard for like their entire life and they
get it cut short when they built a life where basically he could
have spent his like entire 40s and 50s just being with his kids.
He could have been like a real dad and he seemed like the kind
of guy who might do it. >> It's the young >> remember.
Okay. Okay. I I understand my chat's way too unhinged for that.
They're way too deranged. are way too >> that you have
when vibing with someone and you're speaking about things that
you don't >> I I think he was like a bad person but also
I just feel pretty like about that that idea feels so bad cuz
like I'm I've always just enjoyed life a lot more than like some
of my friends some of my friends work like really hard and I
noticed they like let a lot of things go by them okay they don't
pay attention to people in their lives
and I feel like Charlie could have easily been a guy like that
right and he never got a chance to go back and enjoy like that's
what a lot people do. They work really hard. They build something
to build the nest egg and then they go out and they they retire
with their families, right? And I don't think he's going to get
Well, sorry. I don't think he's going to get to do that.
Something tells me he might not get to do that anymore.
Sorry, I was I was going through a normal way of speaking there
and forgot who I was talking about for a second. >> Don't
understand as we were coming up in politics, I always felt like
an alien. We would have these discussions with donors and we'd
have discussions with people or people would do stuff and I would
just tell them all the time, Charlie, I'm an alien. I am new
on this planet. I don't understand this. I don't understand double
speak and, you know, contracts and people threatening to sue.
It doesn't make sense to me. I have an alien. And Charlie always
said he felt like he was a time traveler. And this is a conversation.
I'm an alien. I just messaged him from across the road. He said,
I think I'm a time traveler. This is this is my home. It's so
gay. This is the gayest content. Oh my god.
St. Charlie used to text me. Here's here's some more St. Charlie
leaks, guys. At what point do we believe at at what point is
this just the um
At what point is this not just going to be like Tupac? It's like
did Tupac really record this album from prison and we just never
heard it or are you getting somebody else who sounds like Tupac
to go and recreate this so you can make money off of it? Which
one is it? Which one is it, Candace? Are these authentic real
Charlie Kurt DMs or have you just started fabricating Charlie
Kurt DMs because you know you get 100,000 viewer streams when
you pull them out? Okay, which one is it, Candace? Which one
is it? He felt like Earth was his planet. But I think you found
me in time travels with me. Like the kind of friendship where
you can talk about being a time traveler and feeling like an
alien as I've always felt like it because I don't get it. I don't
get the rules of this planet. I don't get the betrayal, the backstabbing,
the people that dance for money. It's never made sense to me.
From the time I was a kid, I just felt >> I should see
that big pop up when he
>> about being a time traveler, right? All the backstabbing
the people that dance for money. It's never made sense to me.
From the time I was a kid, I just felt out of place. And I am
out of place in politics. I will tell you that because this is
what it's all about, right? selling your soul to the devil. And
I don't want to do that. Anyways, that's just going a long way
of me saying that I'm going to miss the ignorance of our political
youth, thinking that it could be fair, thinking that we could
just work hard, thinking that we could run a company, that we
could launch this revolution where people weren't going to be
happy in the future because America was the land of the free.
I had to mourn that. Now I realized and as I've expressed that
this is missional, Charlie knew he was going to die young. But
there was more that were in those now seemingly prophetic text
messages that I was unwilling to share at that time. But I am
going to share that now when he was speaking about his death
and the vision that he was having in April of 2018. He also said
some other things.
>> Dude, I actually
I legitimately
Do you think Do you think Erica Kirk would have the right to
like subpoena her own husbands, her dead husband's text messages?
Cuz I swear to God, in my head, I feel like I'm almost positive
Candace would fabricate all of these to just support whatever
she's saying.
I actually I think I don't think any of this is going to be I
have no confidence any of this is real. when she says, "Oh, I
had these sex with Charlie Kirk." I I actually don't believe
it. >> He didn't just say that he was gonna die. He didn't
just say that at Turning Point was going to be the death of him.
But he also wrote this in April on April 13th. He wrote this.
He wrote, "Ish like tonight is what I have foreseen. This won't
result in anything. I'll give you the context in a moment, but
in our lifetime, we will experience real war beyond anything
that we can fathom. Absolute and total destruction." Now, for
historical >> Charlie Kirk Charlie Kirk at the end of the
night went outside, hit the vape pen and texted Candace Owens
his up thoughts. We're going to experience real destruction in
our lifetime. Candace, you have no idea. Candace, >> reference
what was going on that week involved, of course, France, right?
America, France, Israel, the Middle East, Syria, Russia, uh,
and this is the Syria before Israel and the United >> Oh,
don't worry, Trucker Joe. Trucker Joe asks, "I really don't think
Erica will ever respond to this. I mean, she hasn't yet, so yeah,
I don't think she's ever going to."
Uh, I think Candace, listen, spoiler, little spoiler for later,
Erica gets brought up in her talk with TP USA. Okay, Erica gets
brought >> through Assad. What was going on was the United
States and France were carrying out a series of military strikes
involving in aircraft and these shipbased missiles against multi
multiple governments.
>> Charlie Kirk, can you hear me? Charlie Kirk, please
save me. Charlie Kirk, Charlie Kirk, please.
Please save me, Charlie Kirk. >> It's in Syria. And the
official reason that we were told was it because the
>> Somebody Does somebody have the video? I don't I will
never be able to find it on my own. Does somebody have the video
of the Dallas shooter firing at like the ICE cops and it's like
St. Charlie deflecting the bullets into the
>> government had apparently chemically I need that video
if somebody can find it for me denied in effect if Assad was
telling the truth and I believe he was cuz I think there's a
war on Christians that's happening then the West and the United
States were implicated in part by a false flag attack to justify
a larger military justification. That's kind of something the
West does a lot, right? False flag attack, get the media going.
We have to respond and then we just sort of take land. Yeah,
that's what we do. Now, France had said in a statement on that
morning on April 14th that France's red line had been crossed.
So, this was a story which Charlie said, "This is not the thing
that's coming, but this is a preview of the thing that's coming.
Missiles, false flag attacks, chemicals, and the Middle East,
America, France, and Israel. It is something. It is something,
right? This was the vibe of something that Charlie felt was going
to happen in the future." Something I used to always say, "I
told you that the rest is future." I think we are in the rest
right now. We are approaching that future right now. And I didn't
feel that then in 2018, but I feel it now. I've been telling
you guys I have been having a lot of >> Hold on. I got
I got it. I got I think I found it. >> Oh no, I didn't
find it. [__] Hold on. >> And the dread that
Charlie felt in 2018. I have been feeling I felt it leading up
to Charlie's assassination. I pulled my children out of school.
I was having uh this dreams and visions about bees and organization
that was happening in America. I have a sense of dread that a
lot of these uh events that are happening, these inextical events
like the Malibu fires, these sort of coastal events, uh the Texas
floods. Is she saying it's saying while I'm trying to Google
[__] She's like actually Is she saying it's the like
we're in Revelations right now?
Like she's dreaming about the end times like the all the disasters
that will come about. >> It's not happening by accident.
Okay. I I have a feeling of a sense of dread that the Fed is
taking taking from Americans right now and that we are heading
toward war. Okay. I'm going to share that. I feel that we are
headed toward war, that they want war by any means necessary
and that you need to be wherever you are in the world fully dialed
into that. Okay? We can't be stupid this time. We cannot believe
what the media is telling. >> Oh. Oh, that's a good conspiracy
theory.
okay, what people will tell you is like immigration is good.
Immigration increases the economy. I immigration's awesome, right?
People will tell you this, but what if it's just bringing in
and and then everybody's like, "Wait, why are you bringing in
like all these single like working age men? That doesn't make
any sense." Oh, cuz we're actually going to go to war World World
War II pretty soon. We're getting ready for war with China and
we need as many fighting age men as we can get. That's why every
Western country is bringing in as many people from like India
and other places they can cuz they need the infantry. I I sorry,
I'm saying that would be like a You could That was way too on
the nose, right? But you could write something. You could make
a conspiracy out of that. It'd be pretty easy. Chimsky, this
one. >> Please be it. Please be it. Please. Yes. 100% this
one. Yes. Thank you. This is
>> absolutely this one. Thank you so much. Thank you so
much. Thank you, St. Charlie, for protecting Americans. That's
like the best. Oh, it's such a good meme. Okay, hold on. Not
believe whatever it is. >> Wait, hold on. Alien mode says
they missed it. I'm gonna play it again.
>> I'm going to play it again.
>> He's so powerful. He's so powerful.
He's so powerful. >> Going to happen. And we're going to
be told that it was this guy. We have to start to recognize the
pattern of things, okay? The uh predictive model of this is my
red line and the red line gets crossed and people are denying
it. And what happens? Christians are mass slaughtered every single
time. Propagandize people Christians in the east who hate Christians
in the west and there's just less of us by the end of it. And
these things tend to happen. World Wars when they want a reset
because people start waking up. And so I just wanted to express
that to you that I feel that we are reaching that brink right
now. And you need to prepare for that. And feels like an almost
inevitability because wars are planned in boardrooms, okay? In
boardrooms. They're going to send you and your children and your
sons, but they are not going to fight. And I don't love a scenario
right now that's happening where we have envoys being sent to
Russia and Israel and everybody's needing all this. It feels
like something's coming. And I know that you probably sense that
dread too. Turning our attention to turning point. Did you know
I learned this from one of our sleuths that turning point might
potentially now be
dude the I can't believe people are like envoys are going from
one country to another. I can't What is this? They call it diplomacy.
But has anybody ever heard of this before? Diplom Do you even
know what diplomacy? What does this even mean? I've never heard
this word before. Diplomacy. What is that? >> Turning points.
Did you know I learned this from one of our sleuths that Turning
Point might potentially now be becoming a real estate empire?
Apparently Tyler Boyer has a younger brother who for 10 years
has worked in dental sales until Charlie died because a unique
opportunity presented itself at Turning Point USA where Tyler
had begun telling people that TPUSA plans to roll out a program
to build houses for first-time home buyers. They're going to
use Turning Point USA's position and audience to market this
idea of new homes. Um, and the marketing pitch is that Charlie
preached to young Christians about how school and universities
was a waste of time and that it was a waste of money and that
they should get married early and they should start their lives
and they should have kids, but he never really taught them how
or what they should do next. So, they are planning to leverage
Turning Point USA's position with young Christians as a captive
audience to sell to build and sell houses. Okay, that's what
the person told me and I checked that out. They presented some
proof of that conversation happening and I think that's interesting.
I think we should share that and I know I'm sure that that's
probably what Charlie wrote. He apparently had a 15 20 year plan
according to Frank Turk. Uh or was it Rob McCoy? Rob McCoy said
that. I think they all said it honestly, but Rob McCoy did say
that he kept this in his notebooks and so a real estate empire
could be on brink for turning point USA. Amazing. That really
is something. Anyways, you guys, we are going. >> That
really is something. Okay, now we had that. I believe we have
this is the Blake guy responds to basically everything Candace
is saying. Okay. Not not >> not literally responds, but
he he This is the guy. This is I [__] Who is this?
Hold on.
Oh, I looked up who this guy was and then I I totally lost it.
Let me just check his Twitter profile. He's big at Turning Point.
Producer for the Charlie for the Charlie Kirk show. Okay, so
he's talking about basically they're going to throw down the
gauntlet here. Okay, they're going to invite Candace
on the stream. Hey Candace, we're going to do an event and we
will h you can come and ask your questions directly and we'll
actually talk about it. Candace, why don't we do that? Candace,
wouldn't that be a good idea? Couldn't we hash this all out?
Candace, >> to use this segment at the top of this hour
to say something important, something very important. For the
past 2 and 1/2 months, there is a topic that has flooded our
freedom inbox. It has been non-stop on social media, but which
we have almost totally avoided on this show. You probably already
know what I'm talking about, which shows just how ubiquitous
it has been.
Ever since Charlie's murder, Candace Owens has leveled a flood
of allegations against people at Turning Point USA, people at
Turning Point Action, and people who work for this show. She
has made them against some of Charlie's closest friends, and
against some of his most dedicated employees.
She has suggested that Michael McCoy, Charlie's chief of staff,
knew Charlie would be murdered, was happy that he died, and stayed
silent because he was told he would be the next Charlie. She
has suggested Michael is not his real name. It is. I have seen
his birth certificate myself. She has called it suspicious
that Mikey's. >> He's going to list all the things he's
she's getting the court transcript read on all the things she
said. Okay. Not good. Not going to sound good to an audience.
at Turning Point helped plan the campus tour event where Charlie
was murdered, which she didn't, by the way. She doesn't work
on campus events.
Candace has suggested the Utah Valley University event was unusual
and its details suggested a quote inside job. She has claimed
that foreign aircraft have followed Erica Kirk around the country
and that Turning Point has lied about this happening. She has
accused us of lying about Charlie wanting Erica to take over
for him if he died. She has suggested Charlie's security team
intentionally denied him first aid after the shooting to ensure
that he died. She has raised suspicions about the head of our
technical team because he took an SD card out of a camera. She
has spread absurd claims that Tyler Boer, who we just had on
the show,
abuses male interns. She has suggested that TPUSA faith affiliated
pastors like theologian Frank Turk who we'll have on in a
>> Thank you Charlie by not by not helping him out. >> And
Pastor Rob >> I like he was he was going to make it. He
could have made it but for some
but for a lack of intervention. Okay. They just need to put some
weight on it. Just put some pressure on it. Okay. He would have
been fine. >> McCoy are part of a military.
>> Do they actually need to take her seriously? Is she
that big?
I don't know how to say this in the right words. Yes, but like
I the scale of is she that big? I can't even put it into words
for you. Okay, hold on. Um,
Playboard
Playboard.co.
Hold on a second. Andis Owens. Is she that big? Is she that big?
Do they even need to pay attention to her? Let's see here. The
average peak concurrent viewers or say the average peak concurrent
viewers for the past month, 137,
204.
Most people who stream around like my space and in this adjacent
space, if they got 100,000 views on a video after a month, they
would be psyched. She gets 130,000 concurrents.
She averages over a 100,000 concurrents in the past month. This
is playboard.co.
She is literally
She might literally be bigger than I show speed.
I'm not joking. She might actually be bigger right now. She might
be bigger than I show speed. That's crazy. That's [__]
nuts. Now, I hope it's going to it's all the like it's all happening
before like a major downfall. I hope. But who knows? Infiltration
of Turning Point either because they are veterans or because
they have family members who are.
Even if not everyone has been named specifically though, Candace
has effectively tarred everyone here with complicity in Charlie's
death by repeatedly saying he was quote betrayed by quote everyone.
She has said Charlie's murder quote had to be approved by Charlie's
friends and then suggested those friends might have her murdered
too for quote knowing the truth.
She has made claims of financial impropriety and fraud at turning
point.
>> Who knows how many people take her seriously. I mean,
I don't know what you mean by take seriously. If you sit there
and watch her whole stream, you take her seriously,
right? Like even if you even if you're watching it like passively
and you think, okay, like I like I don't necessarily believe
this, but it's very
I you're still giving her the money. You're giving her all of
the reward. like literally all of the >> adding up into
the millions of dollars, which again is not true. Charlie made
sure the organization was audited by a third party every year.
He personally reviewed and he signed off on every expense report
and literally every single bill paid by the organization down
to a single United States dollar. We have never missed a 990
deadline.
Candace has made other stranger allegations involving French
paratroopers in maroon shirts. uh Egyptian Air Force planes flying
out of Provo, Utah, and potential underground assassins traveling
through unseen tunnels. At this at one point in early November,
she started wildly throwing suspicion on members of Utah Valley's
soccer team for wearing hoodies. I could go on. There is always
something new coming up. And none of >> Dude, no way. Hold
on. Where's the soccer team? Where's the soccer team thing from?
I don't believe that. I don't believe she went the soccer team.
What was the soccer team? Now, I'm not saying the soccer team
was like in on it, but I just want to know where they were in
the hour before the shooting. I just want to know. I feel like
that's a valuable question. I'm just saying that it's something
we could know. There's no reason for us not to know that. Can
you think of a reason why they wouldn't want to tell us where
the soccer team is in the hour before the shooting? I can't think
of any reason that ever pans out. Because from the start there
has been nothing there. The attacks and allegations from Candace
are either lies or they are innuendos thrown around with a total
reckless disregard for the truth so that Candace can manipulate
and string along an audience of people who don't realize they
are being played instead of being able to grieve properly after
one of the most heinous murders in
>> I will say this guy's going to lose on vibes. This guy's
going to get totally orura mogged. That's like the unfortunate
thing. Get completely
This guy This guy can't beat Candace. He is not strong enough.
Like it's not even close. You need like a Fentes to take down
Candace. I'm sorry. Fentes. Fentes can actually like fight back
against
This
you're I'm just going to dryly read the facts and that'll be
Candace. Yeah, that's done. That's done it so far. You know what,
Ben? That's the one thing Ben Shapiro couldn't do. He couldn't
dryly read some facts.
That's that's the one thing he couldn't do. Okay,
you just need to call her like a stupid.
That's what you unfortunately that's what this situation calls
for. Shut up, you stupid.
But this guy's not he's not strong enough. He can't do it. history,
a murder many of us had to witness, my friends, have had to endure
harassment from people who have gotten whipped up by what Candace
is saying. In fact, I would say we have suffered more harassment
from these people than we have from Antifa supporters who overtly
celebrate Charlie's murder. And just like a lot of those Antifa
members, many of these people take this delight in how gross
and unpleasant they can be. What our friends have had to endure
is not funny and it's not insignificant.
It is evil. I have seen it.
For months, we have received hundreds, thousands,
emails and calls asking us to respond. People have wanted us
to invite Candace on the show. But for a long time, our approach
was to say nothing. We did that for several reasons. First, we
first we thought that her prearications were so absurd that nobody
would believe them. We shouldn't have to answer questions about
secret tunnels or Egyptian Air Force planes. That sort of thing
is just it's beneath contempt to respond to. The second reason
we've said so little though is because there's a good rule of
thumb which Charlie followed. Do not feed the trolls. Focus on
the mission. Reviving America, uplifting young people, making
heaven crowded. Don't give air to people who want to tear you
down. And so discord. Lastly, we didn't respond because
Charlie always viewed Candace as a friend and we were holding
out hope that she would return that friendship and stop what
she was doing. But a week from now, it's going to be 3 months
since Charlie's murder. Candace has not changed her behavior.
She has continued to spread falsehoods about Charlie's friends,
and she continues to concoct new ones, about new people. She's
using these falsehoods to enrich herself while dividing the conservative
movement at an absolutely critical time for this country. And
far too often, we here have heard from ordinary people, people
who loved Charlie and who Charlie loved so much in return. These
people have expressed the worry that we are staying silent out
of cowardice or as some sort of tacit admission that some of
the attacks are true. Neither is the case. Our silence has never
been and it will never be equal to complacency or approval. Still,
we decided Charlie would not allow this to go on. Charlie was
not a coward. Charlie was a fighter. Charlie would not allow
someone to spread lies about the people closest to him with impunity.
And he would feel ashamed if other people were stepping up to
defend his friends while he never did so himself.
Uh, that's not true at all. Charlie was a total who dodged the
people who were critical of him. But, but
I appreciate that you're not you're going to go get or modded
by Candace Owens. Or maybe this is the end of Candace, but I
I don't know. It could have Oh, man. And I don't want to spoil.
Okay, we got to keep watching. Keep >> Candace has mentioned
several times that the ball is in our court. So, here's what
is going to happen. In the near future, there will be a live
stream here in Phoenix where we address in a clear and comprehensive
way the claims and accusations, the false accusations that have
been made against Charlie's family, friends, and the people here
at Turning Point. We plan to walk through everything carefully
and thoroughly. If Candace is available, we would sincerely welcome
her participation in that live stream at our studio here in Phoenix.
At this point, we believe the ball is back in her court. Our
motivation for doing this is not out of any obligation to Candace.
It is about honoring Charlie. We feel a deep responsibility to
protect his legacy, his work, and the truth. I feel that. I owe
Charlie everything in my life. It I feel it immensely. And that
is why we feel compelled to speak clearly and openly now. >> We'll
have more on this in the near >> We Okay. So, so basically,
he does kind of throw down the gauntlet a little bit.
>> Hey, Candace, we're going to you you can come on. We're
going to actually talk to you. We're going to debunk everything.
It's over for you. Now, Candace, of
Oh, and he also announces as well that Monday, December 15th,
is when they're going to respond.
They say we'll be live streaming for Charlie's Phoenix studio.
Our offer from yesterday holds. If Candace wishes to join us
in person in Phoenix, she's welcome to do so. She can let us
know by the end of the day. Okay.
Now, to me, for me personally, I would expect Candace to go,
"Oh, you guys took the bait. I got you. Let's go. I'm gonna crush
you guys." Right. But what she actually did was um like totally
out in every imaginable way.
Kind of weird how you guys kind of weird how you didn't email
or call me to ask about times or availability and chose to instead
tweet this confirmation out at midnight. Why am I learning about
this on X? December 15th does not work in person and 2 pm Pacific
is also literal time I do my podcast is the also the literal
time I do my podcast live every day which you guys knew and we
but we will happily cancel the daily podcast and we'll join you
guys virtually instead for the live stream on the 15th if that
works on your end. Let's lock it in.
Um we'll also add that I'm happy to jump Oh wait, hold on. This
isn't the part. Hold on, hold on. That I'm happy to jump on Charlie's
show any day before then virtually as well. I was serious when
I said we could do it today even virtually. I can make it happen
pretty much any day because it's easier to move things around
with kids and find someone to sub for my morning homeschooling.
Oh, this is actually way less bad than I thought. Damn.
But hold on. Wait. We got to We got to keep watching. Okay, we
got to keep watching. Fentes didn't like that. Okay, Fentes didn't
like that. It's not. It's not. It's not. Just watch. Just keep
watching. I I merged things. Just hold on. You're invited to
the TPUSA HQ to press their leadership live and in person about
their role in Charlie Kirk's murder, but you can't go because
of a scheduling conflict. Lol. Isn't that Isn't this what you've
been pushing for since September? Time to put up or shut up.
And she responds to, "Nick, you spent over a year attacking me
on your show. I finally said, "Okay, come on my show." You responded
and said, "Wednesday worked better for your schedule. Stop being
a fraud." If I had instead publicly tweeted, "Nick refused to
debate." I would have been
Wait, I don't think they did. They publicly She said I think
they said if she wants to join us, she can.
I don't think they said you refused, right? I don't think so.
Okay. And then we get the next show. All right. She got >> All
right. You guys have >> Okay. Also, Tim Pool went at her.
Okay.
>> Tim Pool came at the Queen
and he is
I think we watched Tim Pool complaining about her. I think we
actually watched that uh two or three days ago. Okay. I I kind
of I might want to watch that. Hold on. TPU says in person. Ah,
we got to watch the whole thing again. God damn it. We got to
watch her whole thing >> I feel like I have to ask this
question on behalf of the entire world. What the hell is going
on at Turning Point USA? What's going on? I want to know what
is happening over there in Arizona. Who is in charge? Exactly.
Who is making the decisions? Who is uh calling the shots on all
of these terrible and extremely obvious PR moves? Just I think
we all deserve to at least know what's going on. It feels like
this company is going to turn into Enron, right? Amazing. And
then just plummet overnight. I have just the lack of transparency
and also ironically the transparency of the things that they
are doing. Uh you can't make this up. They are just so obvious.
So obviously trying to hide something. Before we get into their
frankly bizarre late night tweet and ultimatum, I wanted to update
you guys and let you know that Cam Higgby, remember that? >> Hold
on, hold on, hold on. Trucker Joe, no spoilers. >> Propagandist
reporter who goes to the Pentagon press secretary and is like,
"Don't laugh. >> Look at this. Remember that. >> Look
at this ugly. Look at this ugly guy. Look at this. Have you ever
seen anybody uglier or
I'm sorry. That's what I see. When she puts that up, I feel like
that's all I hear. That's all I see. That's what she's doing
clearly. It's like a totally normal looking. It just looks like
it looks unironically like a fusion of Aiden and Perry. Yes.
Like it's just both of them fused together. Yeah. It's like that
per That's who that is. Tell me it's not who who's saying no?
Who's saying wrong? propagandist reporter who goes to the Pentagon
press secretary and is like, "Don't laugh." Okay. Right. Don't
laugh. And then proceeds to ask if they heard about France's
assassination attempt on my life, which I also said in that on
the ground the day on the day that Charlie was assassinated.
Yeah. This camp Higgby, take a listen as well. >> Yeah.
So, this is my first question and don't laugh. Does the DO have
any evidence at all of a French military plot to >> That
is an interesting question. Um, not that I'm aware of. Uh, but
you know, interesting question. I can try to find out and maybe
let you know. Uh, I think that might be more of a law enforcement
matter though. >> So, I brought that up because it was
just so um propagandist. So, in our faces, I I obviously did
not think that this was going to
>> When people laugh at me, that's propaganda, guys. When
people laugh at me for the crazy things I say, that's propaganda.
You're they're propagandizing for USA. But little did I know
that we can add Cam Higgby onto our list of brand new. You know,
everyone was just so brand new on that day. Uh, everyone was
so brand new leading up to Charlie's assassination. Well, Cam
Higgby is on the payroll of Turning Point USA beginning in August
of this year. So, in theory, Cam Higgby, who was laughing off
the idea of an assassination attempt, is being paid by the very
organization that just had its leader assassinated in broad daylight
in front of the entire world. I find that to be interesting.
Who directed him to ask that question? I'm just asking questions.
But first, after my episode >> Oh my god, I suddenly just
realized Oh, I bought a different Oh my god,
now I know exactly why my whole head got [__] up
the other day. Oh Jesus. Okay. Sorry not to cut out something
totally just me. Okay. Just me alone.
I'm sorry. She is an insane person.
Um, no, no, no, no. I just realized that the drink mix I get,
it actually doesn't stay suspended in the water for very long.
I just noticed that it was like all piled down on the bottom
of my cup. And I think the other day when I got that migraine,
it was like a caffeine migraine. I didn't know why. It was probably
because I had like 100 milligrams of caffeine in like 2 ounces
of water and I probably just like at the end of the night was
just like, "Oh, I'll like I'll I'll finish this off." And I drank
it probably like like probably 200 milligrams of caffeine or
something, I'm guessing. And just like burn just destroyed my
brain with no extra water or anything. Yeah. No, that would have
been bad. I I wouldn't be able to like I wouldn't be able to
like kill myself with that. Obviously, people say OD, but never
had pre-workout. No, I have. I drink like stuff like that's basically
akin to pre-workout without a lot of the other [__]
in it all the time. What I drink instead of coffee, but I uh
that's definitely what caused it. I just realized that all of
this I don't buy gamer subs. It's like no-name branded stuff.
I just bought like a different brand today cuz the the other
stuff I was using got expensive. I think Amazon was doing the
targeted pricing thing. So, I bought a different brand and it
just doesn't stay suspended in the water very long. assassination
attempt is being paid by the very organization that just had
its leader assassinated in broad daylight in front of the entire
world. I find that to be interesting who directed him to ask
that question. I'm just asking questions. But first, after my
episode yesterday, I expected call me crazy. I expected that
turn to reach out to me via text, via email that they would instantly
follow up with their long diet tribe and be sincere and say,
"Okay, here are some dates and some times. When would you like
to make this happen? We're going to stop this great debate."
rather instead of hearing anything from Turning Point, I heard
from Skylar, my executive producer, this morning via text, which
I'm going to show you, that I was somehow already 9 hours into
a 24-hour countdown that was issued by Turning Point USA. Here
is that text exchange with Skyler this morning. 8:49 said, "I'm
sure you saw this." And I responded to him and I said, "No, actually,
I didn't see this." And I opened the tweet which went out from
Blake Nef around midnight last night and here's what he wrote.
Like, how am I supposed to see this? The live stream we announced
on the show Wednesday has been set. That would imply to the audiences
that they reached out to me and we said a time no. He goes on
at 400 p.m. Eastern, 2 p.m. local time on Monday, December 15th.
A collection of Charlie's friends will respond to statements
made by Candace Owens to set the record straight once and for
all prior to the opening of America Fest. Now, if it's going
to be once and for all, it sounds pretty final. I mean, I would assume
I have to contribute so I could answer back, right? He goes on
to write, "We'll be live streaming, as he said from the beginning,
this is going to be a live streamed event from Charlie's Phoenix
Studio. Our offer from yesterday holds. If Candace wishes to
join us in person in Phoenix, she is welcome to do so. she can
let us know by the end of today. Why? I'm sorry. If you're saying
this is happening on the 15th, why am I getting 24 hours to be
able to respond to you? That doesn't make any sense. That for
some reason feels like this is a BS offer and a really cheap
PR move. There's no reason to issue a 20
uh you get 24 hours to respond to something a week and a half
from now. I don't think it's like totally BS.
It's like not It's like meant to be inconvenient. It's It's like
meant to be inconvenient. No, no, no, no, no. It'd be like 72
hours from now we're talking and you need to respond today. That
would be crazy. This is like a lot of time to prepare, a lot
of time to I don't think it's like that bad. It's It's unfavorable.
It's like obviously unfavorable towards her. >> 24 hour
response and put in the middle of the night. A B there's no reason
to reach out to me and say, "Hey, does this work? Can I check
some flights? See if I can get in there." Nope. This is >> Yeah,
they don't I I don't know how I don't know how to tell Candace.
>> They don't like you. They actually hate
These people who like totally hate me, who I say like their friend
and their mentor. Um, they like weren't nice to me. They're like
not nice to me. You guys believe that? How up is that? >> They
put this up there. >> I'm sorry. They don't like you, [__]
How How confusing are how confusing is that? How is that confusing?
It's not. It's obvious. They don't like >> On the 15th,
the last week of our show is like obviously leading up to Christmas.
That's the last week of our show. Obviously, it's a pre busy
week. So, I'm like, okay, caught off guard by this, but you know
what? I sense this is a PR move. So, let me say you've already
said it's live streamed. If an event is live streamed, of course,
we can make it work any place. I mean, at any time, any day.
We can make this happen, right? Because you're live streaming
it. There's no reason I can't show up electronically. Okay. I
respond to him and I say this kind of weird how you didn't email
or call me to ask about times or availability and instead chose
to tweet this confirmation out at midnight. Why am I learning
about this on X? December 15th does not work in person and and
2 p.m. happens to also be the literal time that I do my podcast
live every day, which you knew, but we will happily cancel daily
podcast and we'll join you guys virtually instead for the live
stream on the 15th. If that works on your end, let's lock it
in. Okay. Okay. We're jumping here. Let's let's make it happen.
Okay, that's the beauty of the internet. That is the beauty of
2025. You can literally be uh any place, anytime, just send me
a link, right? Any place, anytime we can join you virtually.
In fact, today on their show, they had Andrew Kovette joining
them virtually. So, they have the tech capability to do this.
We have tech ability to do this. Let's make this sincere and
do this for people around the world who do not feel that you
guys have been honest and forthcoming uh in terms of >> answers
that you obviously supply regarding Charlie Cook assassination.
Well, if we needed any more evidence that nothing that they do
is genuine and that this was an obvious planned PR move, here
is what Blake tweeted out just now before we went live on the
show. Yesterday, we made made it clear that we would be scheduling
a formal response to allegations and accusations that you have
made. We have decided that that response will be delivered during
a live stream, as he said, a live stream on December 15th. Thank
you for your response, letting us know that you will not be joining
the in-person conversation. We will be proceeding without you.
Why are you proceeding without me? To have a conversation that
is about me. Why am I getting 24 hours to respond? Why do you
need me there in
>> Okay, that's probably okay that they're saying, "Oh,
you have to come here in person and we're not going to do it
with with you if you're uh if you're >> If you are trying
to be sincere and answer the very many questions that I have
brought up on the show, you guys weren't even sincere in what
you said yesterday. You told some glaring lies
>> This reminds me of Do you guys remember when um when
Manny Pacquiao and Floyd Mayweather were trying to schedule their
fight? That's what this reminds me of. Okay. just like consistent
excuses from both sides about how oh well it's just not working.
Oh man, I just I can't make this work with schedule. Oh, we're
really hurt. Oh, we just we just like had a an incident training.
Oh no, we can't have said >> like you lost out on the fight
for their entire primes until they fought when they were both
like 40 and it was like >> So we're supposed to trust that
you guys are going to handle this discussion all by yourselves
and respond to any and every allegation and this isn't just some
planned PR for once and for all. Like I said, this is so obvious.
He is being completely destroyed in the comments because what's
happening at Turning Point. I've seen this happen before is they
now believe that they are smarter than their audience, right?
They think they are smart smarter than their small pocket donors.
They can pull such an an obviously crappy public move like this
and pretend well we tried. We tried. You know, she said she could
make it work and we tried but we it has to be physically she
needs to be in person even though we have shown that we have
people join us not in person and it's live streamed and we both
have the tech ability to do that. If she doesn't make this work
within 24 hours which we can now say that it's on Candace.
This is a disaster. Okay. It is a dumpster fire. That's the only
way to describe what is happening at Turning Point USA today
and right now is a dumpster fire. Everyone can read this for
what it is. As I said, they are getting destroyed in the comments.
Like really guys, really, you're not going to just send us a
simple live stream link and let us join you. We've had people
on this show live streamed. We could have them tomorrow. I said
in response, I said to them, I'll make this work. I also attached
to that tweet any day leading up to the 15th. This is we can
do this virtually any place and anytime. But no, they need to
have it in person in Phoenix on December 15th if they cannot
have me at all. Does that passing the vibe check for you guys?
Or is it does it seem like more posturing and more of a way for
them to simply be in the room with themselves as they all lie
without any person in the room to be able to fact check those
lies who have researched those lies and who have kept a list
regarding the very many lies they are telling. Okay. I maintain
that Turning Point is engaged in a cover up. That is how I feel.
Okay. And like I
>> I thought I thought she said this makes her looks look
bad. Uh there's a part of this where it does make her look bad.
I just don't think we've gotten there yet. So I don't know now.
I don't know how this turns cuz trust me, I put this together
with like some things I some links I got and then some clips
I had.
>> She's kind of winning right now. But
>> just keep watching to say that because this was once
a bright spot in the conservative movement. It is no longer.
They are using uh left-wing tactics, calling us names rather
than answering us questions. It's everything Charlie stood against.
Okay, you don't need to call somebody a racist because they're
asking questions about what happened with George Floyd leading
up to his death. Okay, that is a way that you skip over how >> she's
claimed to be friends with Erica Kirk. Yes. >> Having to
logic is you name call. All Blake Nef did was name call yesterday.
All the pastors have been doing. It's demonic. It's possessed.
It's evil. How about you simply answer the questions and stop
behaving like you're a radical leftist. Everyone can see what
you're doing. That's what I want you guys to know. It's very
clear. Okay? I am not asking people to defend me. You are just
genuinely this transparent. So, I am sorry that I cannot arrive
in person because it's our last week on air uh before the holidays.
I am still very happy and I will say it again to make that date
and time and place because I'm here and we have the technological
capabilities to make it so make it work. Uh we can move it around
and we can do it even at midnight. I will stay awake and I will
make that work for you at midnight anytime. Just send me a link.
In the meantime, we are just going to start investigating harder
because you're not acting right. Okay? You guys are not acting
right and you are not going to be able to get yourselves out
of it by trying to be tricky like that. And like I said, the
fact that you mentioned the Egyptian planes so many times yesterday
without providing a valid answer or reason as to why we should
just ignore military planes are circulating that don't belong
to our country. Uh we're going to stay focused on that. And guess
what? We have some more explosive revelations which lead to more
questions which should be answered. And by the way,
>> I can't do planes. Okay, I don't think I I don't think
I'm going to do the planes
>> I understand the plane updates. Maybe we go back to
them at another point. I'm not doing planes right now. Okay.
I'm trying to get to the TPUSA stuff. Just >> gets laughed
at. >> It's pretty obvious the call went out >> PR
move.
>> The This section is called the PR move to laugh at my
assassination attempt. >> PR maneuver. Why they're sending
out Cam
>> Egyptian planes. Yeah, that's the whole thing with the
French connection tying like the the assassination of Charlie
Kirk to the French government, the French foreign legion and
Egypt. >> They're laughing at uh everything that we say,
everything that we do. That's kind of their their new shtick
is like we're the cool kids. We're going to laugh at you, you
know, trying desperately right now clearly to turn my very real
claim that the country of France tried to me into >> my
very real claim. Yeah, you did claim it. That is a very It was
very real that you claimed it. She didn't say my very real assassination
attempt. She said my very real claim. >> The Zo influencers
are supposed to influence people into thinking that that is just
so crazy and funny. It's so funny. And hopefully with enough
them going out and making videos and pedaling the same talking
point and trying to turn it into like a cultural joke, you're
supposed to ignore the fact that hey, isn't it kind of strange
that neither the White House or the LA Palace or even the United
States Pentagon has formally denied this quote unquote crazy
claim?
No, it's not. It's not. It's not. It's not. It's not.
What
does this Okay, I'm saying it here now. Donald Trump is a lizard
person. Hillary Clinton is also a lizard person. That's why they
were best friends, okay? They're both lizard people. And if they
don't deny this claim within the next 24 hours, you'll know it's
true. Okay? Look at how easy this is. Oh my goodness. >> That's
what Hollywood's for, right? You, all of you at home across the
world, you're supposed to be fat and dumb and easily influenced
by celebrities because like, don't you have any famous friends?
Doesn't even have any famous friends? Like, you want to be cool?
You want to hang out with famous people? Famous people say that
that assassination camp is just funny. That's just like an SNL
bit. Anyways, the always relatable Ben Shapiro is trying his
luck at humor as well regarding my assassination attempt.
>> How many subs for the next hour? Uh, you could donate
if you want. I'm going to probably keep going with this for as
long as I want to keep >> appeared on Greg Gutfeld's show
and he decided to promote his appearance a little jab. Take a
listen to Ben. >> As you can see, I'm sitting in Greg Gutfeld's
seat. But why, you ask, would this be happening? The answer is
I called French intelligence and something may or may not have
happened to Greg. >> It's hilarious. Laughing about actual
violence is apparently hilarious. So long as it >> I will
just be your pay.
>> Donated three. >> I just rewatched the floor is
lava episode of Community and Candace is playing reality is lava.
>> That's the pillow fort building one, right? I think
it's not the blanket fort one. It's the No, no, no, no, no. Sorry.
That's Ashley Paintball replacement season 3, right?
Season four. No, season 3.
Oh [__] Which one is it? It's one of the paintball
seasons they do a huge game of the floor is lava, right? Or is
it Pillow for? I can't remember now. I haven't watched Community
in a long time. I used to know that show like almost encyclopedically
and I just totally got mogged by myself. I didn't even have to
bring it up.
Man, that's an old show now >> in the context of humor.
You know, all is fair and love and laughs. And Greg Gutfeld after
all after all is a comedian. So they're not being tribal at all.
They're just being funny. Remember, I don't make these rules.
I just follow >> You win a >> uh Ken, thank you for
the good. Appreciate it, buddy. >> So, I'd like to show
you another comedian from my tribe. His name is ASmart. And he's
going to make a funny two. And remember, it's never violent as
long as we're telling jokes. And it's said in front of a comedian.
Take it away, ASmart. No one in the United States should be retiring
at 65 years old. Frankly, I think retirement itself is a stupid
idea unless you have some sort of health problem. >> I
wonder if I slap the you would that be anti-semitic cuz I don't
want to be anti-mitted. I just want to slap out >> Never
mind. She won. She actually won. Uh I'm just going to get a black
person to say they want to assault Ben Shapiro. Hey, is that
fine? Is that funny,
>> dude? What?
that's awesome. Oh, and >> United States should be retiring
at 65 years old. Friend, I think retirement itself is a stupid
idea unless you have some sort of health problem. >> I
wonder if I slap the out you would that be anti-mitted cuz I
don't want to be anti-mitted. I just want to slap the [__]
about you. Shut the [__] up. I'm so sick of you coinball
that trying to stay relevant in front of that equipment. Shut
the up. You want us to go to work and grind for the rest of our
life while you sitting in front of the bank of sound? Shut the
[__] up. I speak for everybody that ever woke up
on a Monday morning. Shut the >> passionate, hilarious,
relatable. It's funny. As long as it's a joke, it's funny, right?
French people colluding to people is very funny. French and >> I'd
say all of these things are quite funny. Yeah. Although,
to be fair, I don't I don't actually have evidence for the thing
you said. I know that guy did actually say he wants to slap Ben
Shapiro, but I still think it's funny. >> Sorry. Anyways,
uh more to this PR effort to I don't know, suspend rational thinking.
I think maybe they have worked so hard to poison us over decades
and to uh dumb us down in the classroom that they're testing.
They're seeing right now they just keep repeating things over
and over again if we will just suspend our rational thinking
altogether and follow them. I think that's it. That's that's
what it must be. And Frank Turk has come out and he's telling
us that Blake Nef um we should even though he seems very insincere,
you should know that Charlie told him told Frank that actually
Blake Nef is the smartest man that he knows. Trust the science.
Take a >> The night before Charlie was murdered.
And I'm not just saying this, but I went into his office. This
was after we had a meeting. You were in the meeting, Blake, me,
you, Charlie, and some other folks. And he was going to dinner,
and he said, "Hey, you're going to dinner with Blake and and
Danny." He said, "Blake is my secret weapon. He's the smartest
man I know. And uh he loved you. And for anybody to suggest,
whether it's Candace Owens or any other person within TPUSA was
somehow complicit in his murder is to say that Charlie Kirk was
such a bad judge of character that he put a bunch of traitors
around him. If there's anything I knew about Charlie Kirk is
he knew how to spot talent and integrity and people that wanted
to make a difference for the Lord and the country. It's all just
so unconvincing and emotionally manipulative. It's so obvious.
Like Charlie said that Blake Nap was the smartest person in the
world. So you should just accept that. Okay. And that's what
he told me. He by the way had a very busy night before. He told
Josh Hammer that his book was the greatest thing. Everyone should
buy Josh Hammer's book. Yeah. That meeting with Frank was like
Blake Nap is the smartest person and nobody should question Blake.
It just it was a lot. Like it was he was they're telling us everything
he said the night before except for when he texted you guys and
said that he thought they were going to kill him. Can we get
to that part? Okay, we get it. Mikey's amazing. Blake N's the
smartest dude we know. It's right here in the Bible. Can we get
to the part of the evening before >> Okay, we're we're
getting to the temp going to kill him, which maybe took place
after all of that. All of the compliments that were paid. Guys,
please stop. It's so fake and gay. It hurts me. It hurts. It
physically is hurting me. The level of fakess and gayness that
we are reaching at Turning Point USA is starting to make me go
ow. Okay, please. I'm asking nicely. Can you give us something
authentic? Cuz that's not going to cut it. That's just not going
to cut it. How dare you question the ghost of Charlie Kirk? Are
you suggesting that Charlie could have possibly not had good
judgment? Am I suggesting that I've maybe watched a lot of hours
of IGTV and it seems like yeah, it's kind of a common theme that
when people die, you should question the people closest to them.
Actually, yeah, I am suggesting that it's like a very high percentage
of murders that are committed by somebody else they know. I think
it's like north of 95% of murders and no matter how many adjectives
you assign to people at Turning Point USA, we're not going to
accept this narrative. Okay? We're not going to accept this narrative,
especially when you're lying and you won't tell us the relevant
portions. Who did he think was going to him? Andrew Kovette.
Can you tell us? Andrew, can you tell us? Blake Nef, can you
tell us? Mikey McCoy, or was he just full of fluff? Just full
of fluff at the end. Just want really just wanted Josh Hammer's
book to be sold. H,
you're bad at this. You want to know why you're bad at this?
Because you're inauthentic. That's why you're inauthentic. If
you start talking the truth, you won't struggle with this issue.
Nobody accepts this. Okay.
In other news and emotional manipulation, Tim Fool is having
some sort of a breakdown. I don't really know what it's about.
I don't know why he's tweeting about me all the time. Um, I hope
he gets well, but I do want to address. >> She's in 2x
speed. Yeah. 1.5
>> absurd point that he is making about why we shouldn't
be speaking about Charlie Kirk's assassination. Take a listen.
>> You can come and you can burn everything I have to the
ground and I will happily live in a van down by the river. I
don't care to be number one. I don't need to be number one. What
I care about is what is true and what will help this country
and what works. And she is a scumbag. Okay? And she's getting
worse every day. And she crossed the line. She continually crosses
the line every day insinuating the turning point literally killed
the guy who made them all rich. And I have to and I hear this
in the streets and I at a certain point I'm like, "Holy, we're
going to lose the midterms. We're going to lose the midterms."
Okay, first of all, this face is terrifying. Why, dude? Is she
a vampire?
This is unedited. This is just her in the video. What are these
teeth?
The She got fangs, bro.
She got fangs, dog.
But anyway, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's
fine.
I don't even know why I paused. I legitimately don't even remember.
Oh, right. She's She's pointing out that there's like a pretty
weird argument to make. Candace Owens won't shut up, so we're
going to lose the midterms. I mean, you could just not pay attention
to it. How is can I I think you could like
uh or like just argue with it. Either one,
bro. What? Then we're going to lose in 2028. And it's because
she's a piece of because instead of saying, "Guys, let's come
together and figure out how to work together." She says the stupidest
crap and now everybody's running around divided and broken. For
what reason? For literally what reason? Because they Charlie
Kirk in broad daylight and we don't care about your stupid midterms.
We just don't care. Like they really This is This is how they
view Charlie Kirk. I think was anything in his life real. Tim
P is going off right now because he's like it's not the time.
You guys need to be mules. You need to keep voting in the very
corrupt people that are lying to your faces right now about what
happened to Charlie K. It is not the time because it is your
job to get people into office.
>> Sorry, it's so easy to run this thing from Candace's
angle. Yeah, that was a really, really, really stupid.
Just a really stupid thing to say from Tim Pool. If you don't
shut up about Charlie, you're going to lose. We're going to lose
the midterms.
It's like, yeah, she's arguing that you this guy of course. Just
pretend for a second that she had to. Don't even say that you
think she believes it. Just say she has to pretend to believe
it. If she has to pretend to believe that you, Charlie Kirk,
than saying, "Stop talking about this. We're going to lose the
midterms."
That's a crazy thing to say. That's an insane thing to say.
This is what I mean when I suggest that nothing in Charlie Kirk's
life was real. So, he really thinks he's doing something there.
And actually, what he's doing is proving my point. These people
just saw Charlie as a means to an end. Okay? as a political horse
that they could ride. And so, for whatever reason, they got tired
riding him. And now they're angry because they also were going
to whip the horse, the ghost, the ghost of Charlie Kirk and say,
"We still need you to shore up votes." And it is inconvenient
that people who actually cared about Charlie and saw him as as
a I don't know, human being. A human being want to know why he
was publicly exe.
Remember though, Tim actually believes if Democrats take power,
he's going to end up in prison. Lol.
Okay. Well, then he should come up with some better arguments
that maybe help his side.
I don't know. Either way, either way, we'll go back. Somebody
said that this was a win by get Tim getting Candace to admit
she doesn't care about the midterms. I don't I think she said
I don't care about the midterms in the context of this,
right? I don't think you really get her on saying like, "Oh,
I don't care about the midterms at all. I don't care about It's
like no, I think my friend was killed." Like, listen to what
she's saying. She's saying, "My friend was, so I'm not going
to care about the midterms first."
Right. Yeah. Keep quiet, truth, tell her Candace. What about
the mid Yeah, exactly.
>> We'll need you to shore up votes. And >> this
I believe this was the um
this is the the argument we hear from a lot of people. Okay.
I feel like this is the counterpoints argument. This is why he
supported Bosch after after denouncing food chops as a dangerous
who couldn't possibly be platformed after going after Chudlo
Logic and Queen of both for platforming food chops like a year
and a half ago, two years ago, right? For being a dangerous like
and this was way too far for counterpoints. Okay, way too far.
After that, this guy's really special by the
After that, he didn't go after Vos for the thing and he said
it was because it was an election year. He was doing the but
it's an election year. We can't talk about this cuz it's an election
year. Nice. We have to get B. I know. I know. I really made a
big deal about like
but now we got to get Biden elected. Okay. We got to get we got
to get Biden elected and Bosch can help with that. Now I personally
don't think you should so out about Bosch, but it was incredibly
disingenuous, right? And that's basically
that's basically what Tim P just did to Candace Owens. The totally
disingenuous thing. inconvenient that people who actually cared
about Charlie and saw him as as a I don't know human being a
human being want to know why he was publicly executed in front
of us and why we're being lied to about everything. That is why
Tim's upset because midterms it's going to be my fault, not the
fault of the feds for feeding us BS. It's not going to be the
fault of Turning Point USA uh for lying and thinking that they're
brighter than us and seemingly not caring about the investigation.
Is that going to be the fault of, I don't know, maybe actual
politicians like Donald Trump, who's the president of United
States, and look us in the face and said, "Are we still talking
about the Epstein files?" No, that's not his fault. The fault
is Candace Owens for wanting to figure out who murdered her friend.
Don't you guys get it? Like,
dude, she's incredibly good. This is, by the way, this is another
downstream effect of running on conspiracy theories, making your
like coalition built on the the stuff around Epstein, right?
And not everything around Epstein's a conspiracy obviously, but
the idea that like everybody like the the government is run by
a cabal of that's the conspiracy, right? You reinforce that way
of thinking. You constantly like like boost these things. You
get people bought in and then it just turns out the better storyteller,
the better conspiracy theorist is going to take everything from
you. Okay? They're just going to take everything from you in
the end. You'll never be able to stop. You'll never be able to
go, "Oh, I want to go back to reality." Nope. You taught everybody
to ignore reality. You taught them. And now just the better the
better reality uh shifter. What is it? What do they call it in
SCP stuff? Is it reality warper? The better reality warper will
win. Okay.
Person who can bend time and space to their will. Like uh Andrew,
was it Andrew Tat who said that? That's who's going to win, man.
That's who's going to win every time. Juice, thank you for the
four months. Appreciate it, buddy. >> We're just an algorithm.
Why do you care so much about humans? Like why are you a human?
Like if somebody really dies, you need to focus on midterms.
Okay, that is the point of a tinful show. It doesn't matter what
you are.
>> Stock hasn't realized the US government is run by yet.
I mean, maybe there are powerful up there. Maybe reality bender.
Maybe reality bender. Maybe there's a name for it in like SCP
lore. I think
whatever. Reality shaping. Reality >> I'm going through
at home. I want you guys to hear this, okay? I don't care if
you have family members that are dying, family members who have
died. If you have children that you care about and you maybe
don't want to live in a world that's run by, you need to put
that all aside and vote for whoever the hell Tim Pool tells you
to vote for. I just want to platform that idea. I think I think
obviously there's something wrong with me and Tim Pool's got
it figured out. His soul seems like it's really intact and it's
not for sale at all. Anyways, we'll take a quick break and get
into your comments. >> Also, of course, want to tell you
guys about Nimi Skincare because it is cold outside. December
is here. The weather is dry and if you are anything like me,
your skin is probably feeling it. This is the time of the year
when we all need a little extra help keeping our skin moisturized,
healthy, and glowing. And let me tell you guys, I love when Skare
>> Damn, Nene Skin Care. Okay,
real quick. She did it again today. >> All right, you >> Whoa.
It was Erica Kirk who called for TPUSA to invite me. What? Cuz
she definitely she definitely says she's not going anymore in
this podcast somewhere, but I only saw the clips and now I don't
know exactly where. Okay. because they are extremely extremely
relevant and actually begin today's episode with comments from
yesterday's episode because they are extremely extremely relevant
and they're also hilarious to what we're about to discuss. People
who watch the show are obviously savages. Absolute savages. And
obviously yesterday we were discussing how they rescended the
offer because it had to be in person. Look at this comment. Top
comment. TPUSA takes them 3 months to respond. Also TPUSA, you
have 24 hours to respond. Like what? Seriously, why? Where did
the 24-hour thing come from and why was it necessary? The second
comment, this user writes, Tyler Robinson can appear in court
by video conference. But Turning Point USA says Candace cannot
attend their debate by similar means. Yeah, guys, we are starting
to notice some things. It's weird. And we announced um or it
was announced today that Charlie Kirk's show, which they are
continuing and which once upon a time enjoyed the number one
spot on Apple podcast, has now plummeted. Right, this is a tweet.
Breaking news. news. The Charlie Kirk show has crashed in the
rankings, falling to number 94 on Apple Podcasts.
>> I mean, that's >> even though it routinely held
a top 10 spot in the past. >> Bro, I don't I don't even
know how it held a a top 10 spot. Oh, routinely held, but it
wasn't holding one. Dude, I'll be honest. I don't think Charlie
Kirk like
Candace might like Charlie Kirk. Okay, she that was his friend
or her friend or whatever. Charlie Kirk didn't have the personality
to run like a the top like five podcasts like Candace does. Okay.
He He ain't built that way. He ain't built like that. All right.
Not even
I just I don't I don't imagine he would have ever had a super
successful podcast. Maybe he get he's got the clips. Maybe he
runs Turn Sting Point USA. But can I still fully believe that
Charlie was not as big a personality as people thought? >> He
even reached number one when Kirk was alive. The reason for that
is simple. It is clear. People are telling you how they feel
and they feel that you are not being honest. They feel they are
not getting the truth from the very people who keep trying to
market themselves as his closest friends. And I'm saying marketing
intentionally because it feels as though they have transformed
into a badly run PR firm uh from the early 2000s where you try
to use celebrities to influence the public. You get like you
know Britney Spears and Justin Timberlake to wear your denim.
Everybody just then starts wearing denim, right? And I will add
on to this that I certainly myself am compelled uh I would say
that it's an interesting twist in this debate story if we're
even calling it a debate offer. At least I was surprised. I was
legitimately surprised to hear this morning that it was apparently
Erica Kirk who called for TPUSA to formally respond to the mounting
questions and to set the live stream. At least that's what Blake
Nef is saying on the Charlie Kirk show. uh they received this
morning phone calls from the viewers at home and of course somebody
asked about the nature of how they went about trying to get me
onto this live stream. Let's take a listen to >> Let's
take a listen >> to that question being asked I think uh
from a woman named Gina. Let's take a >> Let's take Gina's
question. >> Oh, hold on. Ryle asked something back here.
Used to be fans of Candace type shows were like wine moms, right?
There seems to be a totally different audience for this now.
What do you think of the demo is? Yeah. No, hold on. No, no,
no, no, no. This is like the Alex Jones show. And blind moms
didn't watch the Alex Jones show. It's like anybody who's totally
checked out on life could watch Candace Owens. Anybody who's
like, I I lost. I'm cashing in. I'm just I listen to Candace
and she tells me how I am by everything, right? How everything's
up. I never had a chance cuz I never had any power in this world.
I never had a chance. It's over. Right? That's the audience that
Candace has. or people who are like, "No, she wouldn't get the
survivalist types." Alex has still got to have total mastery
over those people.
Yeah, I think this would be like blind moms, too. It's like real
time true crime.
She's doing like real like true crime in progress. Okay.
I don't know. I don't know how the No, no, no, no, no. She is
true crime though. She is true crime. That's the thing. He's
like, "True crime in progress. I am literally talking to you
from the middle of my assassination attempt. I I am about to
be assassinated. And here, let me tell you the harrowing details.
And her whole annunciation, everything she does is like true
crime. Gina, >> welcome to the Charlie Kirk show. What's
your question?
>> Hey, thanks guys. Um, can you hear me? >> Yes,
we can. Yes, ma'am. >> Okay. Um, my heart's broken with
the things that are going on with Candace and I'm trying to make
it all come together. I'm not I'm sure I'm not your only fan
that is trying to do that um because of the relationship that
she had with Charlie. Um and one thing that I'm just trying to
make come together in my head is why the invitation was extended
to Candace but not to Candace directly. Blake, I think you tweeted
something out and I don't know if you know I don't know what's
truth and what's not. I do know that she said she she didn't
even see the invitation and it was issued Blake I think at 12:00
on a tweet that you had but or at midnight 12 not noon midnight
and so it was like nine hours later before she even knew that
you said anything about her attending the show and then she's
saying she can't attend in person can she attend on a live stream
or you know and and you guys do live streams all the time and
is is that going to be an I'm just trying to make this come together
>> of course you not so first of all uh
they do open call there's no way they do open Collins on this
show. No way.
What, bro? They must get pranked all the time. >> Well,
uh, our initial statement it was on the show on Wednesday. Uh,
I made it at at the request of Erica. All of this has been uh
at the direction and approval of of Erica uh because she heads
this and so we what we were announcing there is we said she has
said things that are not true and we did not address them for
a long time. We stated the reasons why that we thought a lot
of them were just not
>> we how to put it. >> Oh, I see. >> We initially
just thought no one would believe a lot of what was being said
and we also just we we remembered the same friendship that Charlie
had and we just hoped that this would go away without requiring
any sort of direct statement or confrontation from us. So what
was approved is we announced we are going to respond to this
and what I said was we are going to announce a date soon. We
actually hadn't agreed on it at the time I read the statement.
We're going to announce a date where we're going to respond to
this. And once we announce it, Candace is free to attend in person.
That is what we announced. And so once we agreed on a time, I
announced what the time was going to be. Candace, for her part,
had said, "You name the time, you name the place." That is what
we did. Uh, as for why it was put out at that time, I would just
say,
>> "Who's more skitso, Candace or Alex Jones?" I've said
this repeatedly. I believe it's Alex Jones. Alex Jones really
believes all the things he says. Candace is consistently maneuvering
her speech in a way to try to avoid defamation lawsuits, like
consistently over and over and over again. I believe the pattern
is is like repetitive enough that you could easily argue that
she just uses it repeatedly to make factual allegations and factual
statements without any of the responsibility. I don't think she'd
actually be protected in court, but it's probably enough for
a lot of lawyers to go, "Ah, I wouldn't take a run at it. Doesn't
seem like it'd be a good idea."
I think eventually that will fade. That will fail. Obviously,
the Mcron are suing her, but they're suing her again for a lot
of the things around what she originally alleged. Does Alex believe
in the supplements he sells? That's the one thing that making
me think he's a grifter. Oh, no. And he is a grifter in that
way. I don't think he believes in that stuff. And I think he
realized that that was the way to make money is selling merch
like that. And I think that's what he does. But
yeah, I don't I don't think he believes in the supplements. I
don't think he believes like the markup he puts on a ton of the
stuff that they sell is really worth it. But I think that's his
deal with the devil right there is he he sells like a ton of
basically like doomsday uh what you call like um prepper supplies
and I think some of them are branded to
Why do you think delusion and self-preservation are incompatible?
I don't think they're incompatible. I'm saying that there's more
control here.
Like probably there's something going on where she believes some
of this stuff in a directional way,
but I don't think it's like total self-d delusion where she believes
everything she says. I don't really believe she believes the
Mcronone stuff to be honest. I think that stuff's all totally
fake. It's possible with the Charlie thing she believes some
of it because she was close to him. But with the Mcronone stuff,
I think that's entirely crazy. I don't think she had any difficulty
in finding out what our what our scheduled time was. It seems
everyone found it out quite quickly. And lastly, on the point
of why it's in person, I think it's pretty intuitive that given
what is being said, what the way this has worked is that it's
critical to be in person if you want to be authentic and to be
detailed. And >> that is what we think is a fair request
to make if she's going to participate. But regardless, it is
going to go forward because we have agreed that some response
needs to be made. And so that's going to happen when we announced
it on December 15th. And we actually got to hit it. I'm one person.
>> Yeah, Gina, I'm sorry. We got to hit a radio break here.
We can keep going in the in the break if you want for uh if you
have a follow-up. Um we uh we'll be right back. We're going to
take a break from radio. Be right back. >> So, I love situational
irony like that where he is
actually live streaming with
>> will Candace consider the inperson. Oh, that's what
I was thinking was she basically was like, well, I need to security
bat and that's why she would dodge. But then she didn't dodge.
>> It's like it's not authentic unless it's
>> Well, sorry. She dodged in person. and she didn't dodge
the um
the the network. >> The person is in person and Andrew
Kov is literally not in person as he's answering this question.
So, I guess the show is not authentic or something. I also love
Blake because he's trying so hard not to be condescending in
that bit. It doesn't come naturally to him. He's extremely condescending.
His obvious uh uh how do I say this? Um we're shocked that you
guys believe Candace. We're just very shocked, you dummies. And
his excuse is that the reason he did this in the middle of the
night on X is that that's it's to be expected as if that's some
sort of normal etiquette once you extend an offer. Not only do
you extend an offer, you say that it's a sincere offer. He used
the word sincere. And when she is trying to get around to, hey,
like why does it need to be in person? Just to be clear, Blake
is saying the answer to that is quote unquote it's intuitive
that it is critical to be in person if you want to be authentic.
Let me just find that sentence again because I consider myself
pretty intuitive. Um I am intuiting right now that that is absolute
bull crap. He says, quote, "It's intuitive.
>> I think it's better to be in person to have a conversation,
even a contentious one, but obviously you don't have to be in
person to do it. that it is critical to be in person if you want
to be authentic.
Yeah. Mhm. They think you're stupid. They just think you're you're
absolutely an idiot. And he says that that's fair. What are you
talking about? My most contentious and my most viral debates
have never been in person. Everyone assumes that when you extend
an invite that you're going to do whatever you can to make it
happen, whether it's friendly, whether it's not friendly. When
you say and you come out and you say that you are live streaming,
the assumption is that you are live streaming because you want
the internet to be able to attend, right? That's the whole purpose
and function of live streaming an event is that it invites everybody
to be able to attend. So when you extend an invitation of live
streaming and you don't explicitly say it must be in person,
why would I assume that you're going to re
um the conversations are not good? It's it's literally like not
good. In person's way better. You also look way worse when you
like spur in person. On the internet you can spur a lot. When
you spur in person, it's like way more connected. You can see
the body language of everybody around that person, right? Like
if you just start yelling and talking over the other person,
it looks way less good in person in my opinion than than on the
internet where it can like good look good. >> Send the
offer if I say that I can appear via live stream. Okay, they
never said that when they made the offer and they were pretending
that they were being sincere. They never made in person a point
of their demands. Um they never also said that I had to respond
within 24 hours. That's a hostage situation. Okay, there's no
way that I I could have accommodated all that in a million years.
24 hours to respond. How about let me see if I can make that
work. Even if I could have made it work, which I couldn't have
because my husband instantly said, "No, you cannot do this Monday."
Um, and he runs the household.
>> oh, there it is. >> He has an important thing
going on that day, which involves people from that are coming
in from overseas. But even if I could have made that work, I
would not have within 24 hours have confirmed to them if they
had even sent me an email because I have kids.
uh, my husband said I can't come out and play. He said no. I
can't I can't do that. My husband said no. That's an insane thing
to say is Candace Owens. Okay. What the No, she didn't run. She
didn't run. She didn't run. And this is now I'm getting the idea
that this is totally disingenuously framed on Twitter. Cuz the
way I got this framed to me on Twitter, okay, was she said she
was never going to go. She couldn't possibly do the event because
her husband said no. But that's not what happened. She said I
wasn't going to do in person on Monday because my husband said
no. which is like very different.
I think to make the claim that she really ran with that, you'd
have to like actually give her another date to show up. And she
said she would show up on the internet, too.
>> I would have had had organized things and it would have
just taken longer than 24 hours. And they knew that. What Blake
did say. >> Uh this is where you get first mover advantage.
Poop my pants off. Okay. I know. What people should do is just
make conspiracy theories about her. To be honest, it doesn't
work. uh you you have f she has first mover advantage, first
conspiracist advantage. Now, if you make conspiracies about her
like in response to this, people just go, "Oh, you're just saying
that in response cuz you don't like what she's saying. Everything
will reinforce this, right?"
verbatim
on that day is quote here is what is going to happen in the near
future. There will be a live stream here in Phoenix. So we're
assuming they're live streaming from Phoenix
where we address in a clear and comprehensive way the claims
and the accry
of fangs. The don't pay attention to the fangs. I wish I had
pointed them >> accusations the false accusations that
have been made against Charlie's family, friends, and the people
here at Turning Point. We plan to walk through every everything
carefully and thoroughly. If Candace is available, we would sincerely
welcome her participation in that live stream at our studio in
Phoenix.
Not a demand to be there in person. Live streams happening at
your studio. And you said that this was a sincere request and
you went about it in the opposite manner. which is why it makes
it really interesting that he says in the beginning that that
was done at the request, at the direction, and with the approval
of Erica. And that's interesting for a lot of reasons. A, I think
a lot of us have been wondering like, did she take on this role
and she's actually executing? Are we still going through a transition
phase? Is she still learning the part? How involved is she on
a day-to-day basis? Because some of these actions seem like fumbles,
like absolute fumbles. And you're wondering, is Andrew Kovat
running things? Is Tyler Boyer running things? Is this coming
from Erica Kirk? Because I don't I'm having trouble, I guess,
comprehending
why she would green light something that the internet has now
read as incredibly insincere. Of course, it's insincere.
You know, you market yourself
um you've as as somebody that is passionate about family and
you we can't even get 24 hours to see if we can make things work
and exchange things. Like I that doesn't feel honest. That doesn't
they didn't come across as honest. And you're telling us or we're
assuming from that statement that she approved the statement
that went out referring to people uh as Antifa members like making
us akin to a basket of deplorables because we don't accept the
fed slop like that got her approval to go out. Like this was
read by Erica. That doesn't feel good, you know? And the reality
is is if you deeply care about the legacy of Turning Point USA,
as you all claim that you do, like you claim that you're really
just in this, Blake Nef and Andrew Kovac, cuz we were his best
friends and we love him. Then how can you treat people who are
genuinely people just like Gina, donors to Turning Point USA,
people who got behind Turning Point USA, people who have photos
of them going to Turning Point USA events, who probably have
tickets to go to Amfest. How can you treat people with such contempt?
How could you think they're dumb enough to believe that that
was a sincere offer? That that's how it's supposed to work. If
that's ever in the history ever of people setting up debates,
that that's ever been how it how it's worked. >> I will
be honest. I'm getting like lulled into a I
can only do so much Candace in a day. Okay, we've been we've
been on this for a while.
Strange strange thing I noticed in the blank. I'm going to have
to move on to something else. just arbitrarily. >> Oh,
does 24 hours to respond mean 24 hours to commit? I think I think
what she could have done like there could have been a lot of
ways this worked and it's I think both sides are a little concerned
about doing it. I think what what this what she could have done
was said something like okay
I accept but I need a different date. I accept I totally accept
in person but I need a different date.
I think that could have been I think that could have worked just
fine. >> Picks a time and a place and you admit you had
no time and you did not have a date picked. So there's no reason
you couldn't come to me and say here's two dates that could work
and allowed me to do that. And by the way, you guys >> that's
that's probably what it is. I got to grab some food. Give me
a second. >> Do that. Okay. And one more thing that I want
to put out there cuz your 24-hour demand is ridiculous. It's
silly. Okay. Let's strip it. Let's stop pretending that I I there's
some buzzard that got hit. we can still make this work and I
would like to make this work and I would especially like to make
this work. If you are saying or implying that Erica Kirk is going
to be there
because the reality is um that would be a game changer. I think
that's a game changer. I think it would be very powerful to have
her there um to represent the viewpoints in a way that they're
maybe not being shared by Blake Nef who
>> uh thank you for the five gifted. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. >> Damn. Hold on. Let me uh let me check this
out.
Another hour.
>> I'm playing it by earlier.
um and speaks down to people and I don't know why he does that.
It's not coming.
>> Hey, hold on a second. I always I always like the Glenn
whoever does Glenn's titles always good. Okay, Taylor Len Ethan
Klein is a vindictive psychopath actually destroying his critics.
I feel like Taylor Loren kind of sometimes knows like she knows
80% of the way to frame it sometimes and sometimes she just like
loses it.
But we'll see. This seems accurate, but
I don't know if she can land the plane on this one. After his
long break from streaming, Twitch streamer Misk returns and announces
his girlfriend is having a
bro. Okay. He's dating like an AOC clone. Yeah.
Yeah. >> How she told me she's pregnant. >> Is this
just fake or is AI, right? I Why would it be AI?
This rage bait for sure. I just don't think it's real. I don't
think it's AI, right? Yeah, it just seems like probably it's
just misgifs
to be on the road and isn't course correcting in the attitudes
that are coming out or at least telling people not to be like
late night tweeting like Tyler Boyer and yeah, it would be great
if if you are saying that on the 15th Erica Kirk as as you are
insinuating that she's going to be there, right? She's d she's
directing this thing. Are you implying here that she's going
to actually be in the chair and she's willing to allow me to
bring things and to go over timelines and stuff? Like, can you
make that offer the through the proper channels? Can you actually
say that since you now have more details about how it's going
to work and reopen that offer again? There is no way in hell
um that George can make the 15th work. They just said it. No,
we he shut it down immediately.
Um and with a for a very valid reason. Um and it is not my inclination
to go to Phoenix without having my team with me. Um and my husband
is very much a part of my team. But I will say that I will raise
it further with the Supreme Court of George Farber. If you are
insinuating and actually if you can confirm Listen,
my husband said no immediately. He had really important [__]
going on and he runs the household.
But if you get Erica Kirk there in person,
then oh boy, I'll be there right away. Okay. Really? >> That
you are saying that you will allow me, as you said further in
this, to bring whatever it is because it would be more authentic
if it was face to face. If you're saying that I don't have to
deal with you and this is actually going to be very open and
I can ask every question under the sun. Um I might beg, you know,
I might beg. So I would love to hear from Turning Point USA and
stop pretending 24 hours uh was some like demand that had to
be met cuz that's ridiculous. So ball uh very much back into
your court. And like I said, I want to make this happen. I I
still think you guys can open up for a live stream. I like you're
doing that right now. Um that seems ridiculous as well. Let's
make this work for the people. Anyways, you guys, diving back
into our investigation. Okay, got something very interesting
for you. Now, it is actually common sense that has been guiding
this investigation the entire time despite the federal insistence
that we pretend we don't. >> Dude, cap cap.
>> Have any. And I think there's a compelling element that
we should follow here. Uh if we believe and know um and
have the intuition that this is a deep state assassination, I
do. Okay. And we know that our deep state, the CIA, is involved
in color revolutions all around the world. We should think about
how they organize the revolutions, right? What does it actually
entail? How >> Okay. All right. Strange thing I noticed
in the 910 footage. Oh, strange thing I noticed in the 910 footage.
the Charlie Kirk photo. >> How does our military accomplish
that? What? Through what means? Okay.
And I think it's obvious that they accomplish that through organized
chaos. The chaos, as chaotic as the event may seem, has to actually
be organized. If this is military, it means that um as a state,
we fund and then we coordinate protests. And coordinating is
the operative word. It has to look organic to the untrained eye.
You have to actually make sure that people will believe when
they read the New York Times, um, when they read AP News or Reuters
that all of this just >> They have to believe.
I don't think I See, here's the thing. I would love I can like
copy people's mannerisms very well, actually. I I'm like this
is like a small talent that if I do some actual work, if I do
any amount of leg work at all and copy somebody's mannerisms
very effectively and like switch them in pretty well, but I don't
think I could like copy Candace's mannerisms and make like a
stream out of it. I don't think a man can copy her mannerisms.
Huh. People need to believe that when they pick up the New York
Times.
Like I I just can't I would sound Nobody would take a man seriously
if they spoke like this. A gay man could. No, I don't even think
I don't know, man. >> Um when they read AP News or Reut,
people don't believe this when they pick up the New York Times.
Okay, maybe maybe with the Tuck maybe that the Tucker thing could
make it work. If I think if I think to mix Tucker in a little
bit, there's like elements from Tucker. Well, people don't believe
this.
People don't believe this. Not when they when they pick up the
New York Times and they read the New York Times, they don't they
don't believe this. Huh? Are you ser
Are you serious? >> When they read the New York Times,
um when they read AP News or Reuters that all of this just happened
like back in >> what are you guys
>> Do the Tucker laugh. I I can't do the Tucker laugh.
I've been slowly like trying to get come down from this cold,
right? Like I had a cold and my throat is like
destroyed.
If I try to do the Tucker laugh, I'm going to like or do like
serious like yelling or something. My voice is going to break.
I'm going to voice crack super hard and I can't handle I can't
handle those clips right now. Okay. Can't do it. >> The
Ukrainians were authentically
>> impressions or just accents. No, I don't do accents.
I do like I can't do accents very well. But mannerisms are different.
Mannerisms are different. like just cadances are different. I
can get that part good. I somehow can't get the way of saying
like the syllables differently for an accent. That's like different
to mechanically than just copying somebody's like cadence, the
way they inflect on certain things. I don't know >> and
truly just done uh with their pres.
>> Uh do you only disagree with people who spoke ages ago?
No, you can hop on the stream right now. Why is Gamora? You can
hop on the stream right now and come chat, buddy.
Always take callins. always willing to talk to anybody that we
review content
and um when John McCain went over there and led the protesters
in the streets, he was really representing the voice of the people.
It was not another United States military color revolution. By
the way, if you have not seen that, this is what we do all around
the world. Um uh you should just I'm just going to play a little
bit of this. John McCain addressing protesters in Ukraine before
we overthrew their president. Take a listen. Pre Ukraine
>> people was a US op. He'd love to see it. >> This
is your moment.
This is about you. No one else.
This is about the future you want for your country. This is about
the future you deserve.
A future in Europe,
a future of peace
with all of your neighbors.
>> All right. >> I will say seems incredibly inappropriate,
right?
No, I think it seems incredibly inappropriate. Even if you support
it, I feel like it's incredibly inappropriate. Like you can have
an opinion, but I think going to the country to express the opinion
during a revolution of kind of a kind, I think that's very bizarre
to me. But I don't know, like as a as a leader of another country,
like like as an elected representative of another country to
go to Ukraine and speak that way, I feel like it seems odd. If
you want to say you support Ukraine from the US, that's fine.
I think as an elected US representative to go to Ukraine and
say that seems odd,
especially somebody who's not a part of like the
like the cabinet. Like they're not a foreign minister. They're
not a dignitary. They're not they're not somebody who's there
as Man. Yeah. They're not like an envoy of some kind, right?
Well, I guess they're an envoy of a kind, but they're not like
specifically involved in diplomacy. They're an elected representative.
>> That's enough. I don't know why we're like this. I really
don't know why we're like this. Anyways, I believe in my heart
and in my rational mind as well that Charlie K assassination
was about as organic as John McCain, may he rest in peace, leading
the people of Ukraine. Um, and we got our color revolution and
we've been doing corrupt stuff in that region since. Now, I began
as a function of their elected role. Wait, but is is that a thing
you do as a function of your elected role? You're elected as
a senator and you speak in front of like a revolution in another
country. I don't think that's that seems odd to me. I'd imagine
some senate thing. As far as I know, the State Department is
entirely executive. Is it not? Is there any elected official
that runs things in the State Department? Who's who's the elected
official that like it's the president?
And as far as I know, the State Department is like crafted by
the president. Like if you're an elected official, you actually
Oh, okay. I see what you're saying. Yeah. Yeah. >> Scanning
the people of the crowd.
um obsessively. Obviously, you should see the folders on my desktop.
>> Oh, I'm just dude, this is just it's just incredibly
inappropriate to go do that to try to influence another country
during a time of unrest like that.
I understand that Americans could do it. I I know you can get
away with it. I'm just saying it's inappropriate. >> And
I'm referring, of course, now to UVU on September 10th, and there
was something that I kept noticing. A weird amount of young men
were alone at this event, and they were wearing maroon shirts.
In fact, so many of these young men that I was coming across
were wearing maroon that at first I legitimately assumed that
it had to have been one of the UVU colors. I asked this question
so innocently. I was like to someone at UVU. I was like, "Oh,
are your school colors maroon?" And he comes back and he said,
"No, they're green and white." So my gut told me, "Okay, that's
interesting because maroon is not exactly a highly ranked color
for men." Okay. And it can't be that all these men that are wearing
maroon also happen to have attended this event alone. So, I'm
going to show you what I mean. I'm going to go back to some of
these people. This is by no means everyone. I'm just showing
you a few times here. >> Uh, here we go. We have this this
young man. This is after the shot.
>> There's no way. I went back and watched the Charlie
Kirk assassination footage and I noticed a lot of men
wearing
Bro, uh, as an aside, I love maroon shirts. I have like three
maroon shirts, okay? or maroon or like some version of like Yeah.
burgundy
like that red purpley color. Okay, I'm sorry. I have I have shirts
like that. I have like multiple shirts like that. What the How
dare you, Candace? How dare you? >> Maroon to another person
here sitting there under the tree after the shot. And
>> red or like burgundy goes really well with blue. Red
and blue as an outfit. You wear red bottoms, blue top, top bottoms.
Uh, sorry. Uh, blue top, red bottoms, right? It's like good color
mixing. Yeah, it's good color mixing. >> Wearing maroon.
Show another person here. We're going to come back to this
>> Yeah. I don't know what she's saying. This color is
like in every men's department everywhere. Always. This is like
a specifically I see this. There's shirts this color. I have
like three shirts this color.
She's out of her
This is This is the most crazy she's ever been. Okay. And that's
saying so >> is wearing maroon because his dad is going
to uh say something.
>> Okay. I can just see how like progressing over time
she gets like this screenshot of the the frame where it's the
three guys in the same frame. >> Going to uh >> cuz
I think these are these might be three of the guys she's shown
so far.
>> There's just so many of them wearing >> Say something
publicly. Three people, one shot, all of them alone wearing maroon.
We're going to come back to the guy uh at the top there who has
the hat, the darker hat on who was wearing maroon. Just like
these like strapping young men all wearing maroon. We've got
this guy in the book. >> Okay, hold on. That's a good question.
Uh Charlie Kirk Maroon.
Let me see when when did the skitso theory start?
Okay, we got one guy saying um Charlie Kirk's assassin is wearing
maroon here. Oh, wait. She might have said this. Did I? Oh, did
I did I maybe up and m Saying it that like people wearing is
it is it that people are wearing maroon because that's what the
shooter was wearing? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. That that'll be
the idea, right?
I'll be honest. I checked out for a second. Is she saying so
she's trying to say that basically, you know? No, no, no, no,
no. There's Well, there's this guy in the maroon shirt that I
think is supposed to be H. Where did I put it? I think this is
supposed to be the guy,
Maroon shirt here. Too many men wore maroon on the day of Charlie's
assassination. Bro, there's I'm just looking to see. There's
got to be somebody who said it before Candace. There's no way
cuz like what does that
That kind of implies
that she just watches footage from Charlie Kirk's assassination
day like often on the show.
>> Okay. All right. Yeah, of course. Milo says like this.
Ah, what the [__] >> President, as you well
know,
>> why? Why? Why? Oh, I see. I see. So, YouTube in bed.
I got it. I got it. >> Another break for our sponsors and
then I will get into some other comments. >> All right,
you guys. What do you >> We're not good. >> Push
wearing maroon. I could go on and on. This person wear of how
many people were wearing maroon. I even have a video. No, she's
implying that like people wore this shirt and walked around alone
because they wanted to create like chaos that day that a bunch
of these people are wearing like a maroon shirt and a hat so
that they would go try to find guys in a maroon shirt and a hat
and talk to them and they would not be able to find the needle
in the hay stack >> of someone holding a maroon shirt.
Okay, so I mentioned that quite casually and that thing happened
where there was an overreaction for no reason online. So, I knew
that I was on the right track and I should probably keep going
and I said something. I think it was on X and or maybe it was
on the show and then we received hundreds of emails from people
past and presently in the military around the world and they
said yes Candace that is military. I am just going to quote a
few emails here. One person wrote quote airborne forces wear
maroon uh not just in the UK, the USA and France as well as in
dozens of other militaries. Another person said, quote, "I instantly
recall that when police are in undercover units, the FBI, etc.,
and they are not in their uniforms, they often have a color of
the day or a unit color. It's a signal to anyone else around
that you are with that mission or unit." End quote. Another person
wrote, quote, "My husband was and led part of the QRF, quick
reaction force team, uh, when they were deployed in Iraq. Uh,
we're tired now. We are retired now. The maroon color in the
military means the color is famously associated with military
forces such as the maroon beret of airborne troops around the
world. U >> he legitimately just reads like skitso
Dude, it's
this good stuff. And another person explained to me that especially
in coordinated violent scenes,
uh, making sure that people are in certain colors or in something
that is identifiable is important so that military men can observe
who to protect or who they're looking for, right? And okay, that
just makes sense. Okay? And, uh, so lol for all of you guys that
were saying I'm stupid. I love being called stupid. Every time
you call me stupid, it's another little clue that I should follow
that. You guys are >> guys, I'm not stupid. A chatter said
that Maroon is involved in the military. Listen, a chatter said
that maroon means military. Okay, so for anyone who's calling
me dumb for saying the marine was weird. All right, get loser.
A chatter said it wasn't. >> You're totally reaction to
simple things. And I feel in my gut that it was not some random
coincidence that so many of these fellas decided to wear maroon
on September 10th and attended to the Charlie Cook event. And
I feel even more compelled uh because there was this person on
TikTok, you may have seen it at the time, who was claiming that
he had some videos.
>> I don't think it was possible as easy. I'm sorry. >> Someone
in his family had shot and when he submitted them to the FBI,
the FBI had asked him to delete that footage. Um and I don't
know if that's true. I don't know if that's false. But I do know
that when I got in touch with this individual and he sent me
the footage, my eye immediately gravitated towards another person
who happened to be wearing a rune who is also alone at the event
who I thought it was kind of strange did not duck when everybody
else ducked after the shot went off. I think I had shown you
that. I'm going to show it to you again. We I know I identified
him as a young man named Jacob Kasparian. And I'm going to show
that video of him not ducking after the shot goes off. Take a
look at this. >> Counting or not counting gang vitals.
>> And we're going to circle it so you can see it. Okay,
that's him. You're going to see everybody duck. Oh,
what the bro? His head. His head. His You see it kick back?
That's kind of [__] up, dude. They just circle it.
See it?
>> It's that guy back there. There's this guy who didn't
go down. >> That's him. You're going to see everybody duck
and it's going to come back up and he's still not going to be
ducked. He just kind of hits his phone and walks away.
>> What? He's like He's like having a meltdown. That guy
does like a full 360. Bro, that guy that guy's going one way.
He pauses and comes back >> regarding Jacob. >> He
pauses. He He does a full 360. What?
>> Okay, that's him. You're going to see everybody duck
and >> he goes down. She goes back
>> and he's still
>> He's like there looking down at the
>> He just kind of >> goes to start running. >> Then
he turns around and goes the other
Now, regarding Jacob Kasparian, I want to be very clear. I do
not think he shot Charlie Kirk because it's really fashionable
for people to say that we are accusing everyone of shooting Charlie
Kirk. No, I am observing
uh some things that strike me as unusual and it's unusual that
he attended the event alone. Um it is unusual to me that >> it's
definitely not unusual
unusual to attend the event alone. What bro? What? After researching
him, he had posted himself earlier that day at either 8:42 a.m.
or 7:42 a.m. I'm unclear on whether or not Facebook is editing
uh the time zones according to what I'm in, the time zone I'm
in or when it was shot, but he's wearing an entirely different
shirt earlier that day. It's a dyed blue shirt. And then he arrives
when he arrives to UVU campus. He kind of hits certain points.
He's up high um and then he's at the lower rung 2 minutes before
Charlie gets shot. he's not where he is and then the next thing
you know he's there and the reason why he's not moving is because
he's recording and he doesn't duck and I just found that to be
a bit interesting and I can show you by the way this is a very
grainy image of him recording
um you can we're kind of circling it there okay if you can't
see it we've hyperimposed but I I just found it odd thereafter
that nobody despite him being there witnessing it and having
recorded by the way Charlie getting shot none of his family members
posted anything about Charlie's assassination. He is active.
He did not post about Charlie's assassination.
It happened in their backyard. It was a global event. No comment
whatsoever that I could find.
And I started to wonder based on
>> Bro, is she she's just straight up like doxing this
guy and then being like, curious how nobody said anything about
this. where I found these individuals in the audience. I I started
to suspect, and this is my broader suspicion and theory, which
in any investigation you're allowed to do, it might turn out
to be wrong, but I am beginning to suspect that our maroon boys
in general were tasked with taking footage from predetermined
angles. Again, it's a suspicion. I'd like to explore it, and
the easiest way for me to explore things and rule things out
is to open things up to the public. I I would like to see if
anybody recognizes and can identify these other maroon boys because
maybe I can determine what their extracurricular activities are.
This is okay. This is too far, right? I think this is too far.
More tips at
Hey, out of the 100,000 people watching right now, you can you
go dox these people right now? I listen, GET THEM. GET THEM.
Are they all in the ROC? As an example, um I'm going off of internet
vibes. They could be a part of the Maroon. Okay. >> And
it was even more compelling
uh because there was this guy who live streamed the whole event.
We all know who I'm speaking about. His name is Adam Bartholomew.
I have never ever said anything about Adam Bartholomew. I have
reviewed his footage, but people online were clocking him as
suspicious. They're like, "This guy just always happened to be
in the right place at the right time." And he has been randomly
attacking me. Again, I've never said anything about him. And
one of the ways that he instantly attacked uh was when I mentioned
the maroon thing. And he said, "My son was wearing maroon on
that day." Uh and his son was that's the person that we showed
you. That's Adam and that's his son. Yeah. That only makes it
more compelling because you were capturing footage on that day.
So, I'd like to know more. And I also find it strange, I will
say about Adam Bartholomew, that when the shot rings out, he's
live streaming. Okay. And he does not stop live streaming to
run down and ensure that his wife, who was in the audience, okay,
was okay. He did the I f when I learned by accident that his
wife was there, his wife Carrie was there and she was
>> when I learned by accident when I like went through
all of this guy's social >> standing by the bush actually
almost directly near Jordan Kasparian. He I would have expected
him to be like oh my gosh after he says what is that? Is my wife
okay? Oh my god, where is she? Where's Carrie? Nope. Nope. She
tweeted that photo of herself and she confirmed in her own ex
feed that uh she was
uh I am more than I ever been is what her tweet says when we
thought laying in the courtyard that we were about to get
>> She probably didn't know that he didn't care about her
when the shot rang out and now she does. Candace, thanks. Just
broke up a marriage. Candace. Oh, wait. She's right. You totally
didn't care about me. I was in the crowd. You didn't even come
to make sure I was okay. What the man? >> In the back or
in the head? It was very creative on the right side. She confirms
>> just chucking grenades into marriages. Candace, what
the >> picture and by tweet where she was when that shot
went off and yet he mysteriously was not panic to go find his
wife. I
>> Why do you need foreigners? Is that I mean I'm not American.
Why do you think I'm American? Broke. American politics just
happens to be like the best drama content on the internet. That's
not my fault. That's American's fault. Okay. I just review this
stuff. >> Weird. And I have a suspicion about the maroon
boys. I think all of our footage has come from Maroon Boys and
a lot of that footage uh was then algorithmically boosted. And
so I would like to again show you the pictures of these men.
And by the way guys, there's going to be someone that just gets
clawed in here who just happened to wear a maroon shirt that
day. I am sure. If that is you, please just write to me and let
me know. Like no C, I go UVU and this is just a shirt I put on.
They do look military to me. I will say that. Um, and like these
three I just it's something that I've noticed. And then obviously
we know Tyler Robinson notoriously was wearing a maroon shirt.
Uh, could be Boy Scouts, could be ROC,
could be Eagle Scouts, could very much be Airborne. So if you
guys know anything, please email us. Again, if you recognize
these people, I don't want your broader thoughts on the color
maroon, but if you recognize these individuals in particular,
more tips at
Okay. Okay. And then I'm going to tell you somebody they actually
do think is suspicious on that day and I need to know everything
about him. But first, let's uh get to some sponsors.
All right, you guys. When they double down on abortion, we have
to double down on supremely shady. >> I mean, we've got
Oh, questions about a witness who is at UVU. Okay, bro. How did
she literally spent she like quintupled down into Charlie Kirk
conspiracies and it paid off in spades. Everybody else was like,
"Okay, time to move on to a different conspiracy." And she was
like, "No, infinite Charlie Kirk conspiracies."
And it like 150,000 viewers concurrent.
It's It's nuts, man. Doesn't manga/republicans just like the
color red. Yeah, red, but not burgundy or maroon. No,
different different kind of
It's pretty wild that she just like she started doing that and
it paid off like in spades almost immediately,
right? It's It's kind of nuts in my
All right, let's uh let's see what else we got here. I think
that's basically
>> I mean, there's more there's more CPUs stuff, but eh